this looks problematic for the queen bee
700g check what a shot 95 he wins the
queen
[Music]
no score yet but we will have a match
very very soon hi everybody thank you to
everyone who's already with us more than
500 of you at twitch TV / chess and
chest comm TV me and Grand Master Robert
Hess are we are we're right here for you
to bring you through the next round of
which of these 16 faces will move on
let's talk a little bit about what we've
seen so far just quickly we've seen it
Cara Nakamura move on is the 1 seed
Levon Aronian takedown Fabiano Caruana
but today today's match I'm anticipating
to be a little closer than maybe two of
the I guess lopsided matches we've seen
so far
am I wrong Robert what do you expect no
Danny you're absolutely correct and we
do have a 2 vs. 15 matchup so on paper
at least according to the bracket there
should be quite a one-sided affair but
not so fast wayy has been one of the
stars from China in recent years he's
been well over 2700 for a long time now
so I think this match will be a little
bit more even and he's a young player
he's quite talented in speed chess but
of course Wesley so we all know the name
the face of the American superstar who
had an astronomical career so far but in
the year 2016 in particular he still won
the best players in the world / 2780
fidei and i expect him to be the
favorite here it'll definitely be a good
match oh well this brings our first week
of non-stop action to a close everybody
as we said we've already seen car 1 and
Aronian Nakamura and Yifan and now we
got Wesley so and way let's remind
everybody who who may have forgotten
what the format is - the speech has
championship it's a bracket of 16
players the winner moves on and if the
match is tied at the end we'll have some
overtime games Wesley is no stranger to
a close match had a very very close one
in his first year last year actually I
guess was his second year in the
speeches championship but last year
playing against onigiri was one of the
more exciting ones of course the prizes
that are on the line get drastically
more as as the matches move on and the
players are looking to get themselves
into the final four where there's really
big prizes for just a few hours of blitz
the preview on paper here does have
Wesley so as a favorite
I guess he is the two-seed so we say
that we expect a close match maybe it's
slightly wishful thinking by you and I
partner since we were really hoping for
one maybe but Wesley so is is the
favorite on paper so we'll see if he can
continue to continue to be the favorite
we know that Wesley plays a lot on chess
comm both on his main account and and an
anonymous account that or two that i
won't i won't i won't talk about those
cuz that's not my job but what i will
talk about is that we are we are getting
set here the players are ready they are
situated where you joining us from china
it's very early there Wesley so joining
us from his his well-known kitchen we
love the cabinets behind him Robert
you're joining us from the same place
where I left you like just 48 hours ago
so do you ever move from that spot you
know I did happen to come home just
before this broadcast and you upset with
me if I didn't make time for you to talk
well in advance of the start of this
match that's right but I am back to the
same familiar spot that you seem to know
and love that's right that's that's
where everybody when they visualize I
wonder what Robert has is doing right
now that's where they picture you was
sitting sitting right there so we'll
we'll talk a little bit about the stats
and the odds as the match gets going as
we can see there Wesley so nearly a 70%
favorite on paper and we'll see how that
holds up remind everybody as the match
gets started you can get involved on
Twitter you should do that I I tweeted I
tweeted Robert you ever tweet I do tweet
yeah I tweeted just not too long ago
said that so that we're getting close
nothing like the the Ric Flair the Ric
Flair everybody misses everybody misses
Ric Flair so lots of lots of big games
coming to tweet at us with the hashtag
speech s let us know your thoughts on
the match let us know where you're
watching the match from and we will try
to stay in touch with some social media
as the match goes on but right now we
don't need to stay in touch with
anything but the games and these players
and the match is getting set to start
momentarily in fact the games have begun
Robert take it away well we see was he
so starts with the white pieces and I
just caught your Ric Flair referencing
and as we see actually I have a private
message from my client who's feeding me
stats but he
34:30 Nature Boy which I also really
enjoyed the ESPN 30 for 30 I'm Ric Flair
whoo yeah that's right the legendary and
Ric Flair as I said we it was during the
countdown sometimes I get so jazzed up I
get all the production done in advance
and then I have nothing to do but sit
there and twiddle my thumb's or tweet so
that's you know that's when I get my
tweets on but all right we got an info
you know something tells me between
these two players Robert we are gonna
see main line theory I think Wesley by
nature is somebody who is not afraid of
challenging people in main lanes he's
also just one of the most well-prepared
players on the planet and I know he
really wants to win this match and so I
I don't know that that means we're gonna
see preparation but unlike guys like
Caruana preparing for the World
Championship match I mean this is
something where I expect both these guys
to be bringing it a hundred percent in
the sense that not that they don't
always bring it 100 percent in the
speeches championship but no holding
back as far as the openings that they
really favor and think are the best so
I'm expecting we're gonna see a lot more
main lines today I completely agree with
that assessment um right now we see that
Wesley has just taken the pawn on c5
here so was it with the white pieces
giving his a point this isolated pawn on
d5 now wait well ye he plays a
principled manner with nice c6 because I
was he's playing very quickly at this
point but in this sort of setup black is
going on the activity and inertia
because you pin this knight on f3
you can try to capture it at some point
play 95 but it's not that easy to regain
this pawn on c5 in a very simple
ministry forward manner and especially
with this woman Knight a 4 that's why
players take on c3 with the bishop some
time giving white to doubled pawns and
the c-file hoping to regain that pawn on
c5 but in this lineup in 94 yes look
black and like Queenie 7 to try to get
that pawn but as you'll see that even
once you regain that pawn you're still
gonna have problems in your position
your mate you'll be left with a nice
layup on D file you will have to give up
the Bishop of darks or Bishop to take
this pawn so for example after Queen e7
a3 Bishop takes e5 I can even simply
take on c5 back play pawn to b4
admission to b2 and just you know really
challenged blacks opening choices yep
highlighting that on the analysis board
for the fans I completely agree with you
especially with the bishop here for
white and the potential of this
positional weakness you just you got to
be thinking that White's going to be
getting the better this
and we actually looks like we have
actually seen that line on the board
here no no we're still at the position
with nine a four okay so uh way you
going into the first real think we've
had by either player and down more than
a minute on the clock one thing about ye
is we we don't really know how he's
gonna handle this format these time
controls he doesn't play as much online
blitzes you see Wesley still bringing in
the 3,000 plus rating anybody who
follows him on chest comm knows he's
been north of 30 100 times up there with
the likes of guys like Hikaru and MBL so
I know how Wesley handles himself he's
also got experience here this is gonna
be an interesting start to the match but
but maybe way he's just thinking to get
the cobwebs out of his head it is early
in China and he did just wake up a few
minutes before this got started so we'll
see if that either continues to be a
trend or if he speeds up yeah I think
psychologically is well he just came off
a tough defeat in the term and he's
playing in in China in fact he's a
around what three hours after yeah we
should let the fans know that because
for those who don't appreciate what
these players are doing way he is was
super flexible with us and he yeah he's
playing the lead at the tournament
leader in danzel in about six hours from
now so but clearly he's got his probably
already straight you started the day off
right with some speech as championship
Wheaties yeah and playing was he so is
pretty good preparation you know playing
in four hours because you know you may
say this is speed chess but at the same
time you're playing very serious
openings and it's a very serious
opponent and after this from 94 which
was just played that's a very good way
to go after this pawns yeah I because
white can play a three now but now when
Bishop takes c5 it looks like you may
have an in-between move with Bishop
takes key four but the problem is that
up to pawn takes e4 back the knight on
f3 will be in trouble as well so the
bishop on c5 is left on free but the
knight on f3 is going down at the same
time that it actually seems favorable
for black so you don't want to try to
get greedy for white at this early stage
of the game well I think we're probably
gonna see exactly that line you're
talking about Wesley went into a bit of
a thing himself there I expect wayy to
capture and though I agree with you that
I think this is a better version for him
in the sense that after takes on c5
Knight takes probably Wesley has to save
this Bishop might even just bring it
back to eat udon pin before playing b4
unlike the variation you showed where b4
came with a tempo on the Queen but it
still feels like white will be the one
playing for two results right white will
maintain the bishop here you still have
this isolated pawn on d5 so I guess I'm
still still favoring white and now
Wesley comes up with an interesting
maybe even a creative way to try to win
a piece Robert is he hoping that after
takes a three is he gonna take with the
pawn try to dislodge the knight he
definitely would like to take with the
pawn there but there's some Queen g5
check action going on well yeah go to h2
then I Bishop d6 check uh-huh if you go
you go to h1 I took something straight
forward like Queen h4 or yeah yeah Queen
h4 h5 and all the sudden h3 is hanging
so okay interesting we're gonna find out
right now perhaps Wesley just takes with
the Queen and says I'm was really just
happy to get the bishop pair and not
trying to win a piece but something
tells me maybe Wesley calculated
something he's pretty focused there
remind everybody that of course the
prize fund on the line today is $2,000
cash coming from the initial base from
chess calm any and all of you following
and subscribing and showing your support
all donations raised today go directly
into the pockets of these players and
show them your love if you see something
you like send us a message and we'll try
to read it on air all right we're gonna
get a draw little Brookings well if you
if you chart start going too hard for
white here for example you take this 94
and have Queen take stage three check
and if if King g1 I think I just got a
95 yeah oh he's on the attack that looks
like black is much better in that
situation but if you go King g2 for
white well then you're saving the f2
pawn your saving h3 and it's definitely
feasible we see some kind of Queen g5
Queen h4 but that's what I was thinking
if we're not gonna do that or we might
be headed for Perpetual right that's why
I asked but he goes for it I think
something tells me we have a queen sac
to start this baby off but just 95 here
and if you I guess
95 you gonna try sac with Knight takes
e5 but then I go Knight g4 not even
Knight f3 Knight g4 that way gonna take
on g4 with check that's a really really
great point because this would not have
been as good everybody after takes and
takes white might have an extra move now
to try to get out of the perpetual and
three minor pieces will probably slowly
I'll play the Queen but
I'll move like Knight g4 as Robert said
would be a much much different
experience for white because taking with
check means black now has an extra move
maybe you attack the knight do some
other things to try to get the rook in
the attack so you gotta be careful even
if you get a lot of material for the
Queen when your king is the one open
right because that's exactly how the
Queen flexes her muscles if your King is
under an attack yep and the reason why I
know these ideas is because I have
played the nihms over a very long time
and I remember looking at these sort of
positions years ago you just kind of
give up a piece of white gets greedy and
now if they rook a d8 for example and
rook to d6 and you just go for checking
out Queen g3 check first one of these
moves I'm not sure of the exact order
and Queen g3 checking each one and then
rook d8 looks really good well and
what's interesting is with Wesley
playing a three note everybody he's
conceding a draw right now it's very
clear he said well maybe I shouldn't
have taken that piece because this sort
of approach means that black can black
can take a minute here literally a
minute if he wants to see if he's
winning even cuz even under time
pressure if he thinks he's winning he'll
go for it if not he'll settle on the
draw and maybe say I got on the board to
start with a peaceful result I'm a
little more awake than I was an hour ago
no no way he wants the whole thing
shoutout to Roman chess man who just
came through with our first donation
going into the pockets of Wei Yi and
Wesley so thank you for that
okay f for this yes this is gonna be
this is what I want this is what I want
today Robert can you feel me through the
miles between us in New York just
imagine I'm feeling you right there like
in a good way we're feeling each other
well I mean I know you love sacrifices
that's definitely an Danny wrench
specialty and you also love sacrificing
her queen that I remember you know for
from a long time ago yeah but he doesn't
like sacrificing their queen right he I
would agree to a draw there I think that
black had the upper hand in that game
but you know if your way you draw out
the black pieces can't be too upset with
the way you played but yeah you know
those are the type of games you need to
convert if you're gonna knock out a
player like Wesley so in a long match
yeah but to play devil's advocate right
he's the underdog you know he's he was
black and at this point he's he sort of
held par
in the sense that he's he's now but now
what's the white pieces and a chance to
to maybe be a little more aggressive so
I you know got it got to be something
you consider a practical successful
result for Wei Yi even if I in the long
run we may be agreeing with you that
okay if that becomes a pattern of not
converting when when you have those
chances than for sure I do agree hey
Danny look an opening we have what do we
have tell me
oh just Wesley Wesley follows our shows
closely he probably knows he's trolling
us you know you know it's funny because
Wes he may have been watching the
previous runs I'm not sure but he is a
very very good French player yeah and
you know his French is different than a
lot of French's I feel like I typically
see his French teams a bit more active
he's playing not just to hold off his
opponent but actually try to get an
advantage of his own and his strength in
the French goes way back it's not this
is not a new thing that is but he in his
over the board chest these days he's not
much of a French player just to go to
the top level it seems like you get
punished a little more by playing with
the French opening yes yeah we've talked
about so many times but I do like the
decision in this format to start off
with the French used as a feeler opening
see what way he has in store for you yep
and um well if you it doesn't work out
then you start switching your openings
yeah I agree and obviously many people
know our feelings about the French at
least in regards to at the highest
levels of the results there and you know
we won't get into our bias that if
somehow whenever you and I are together
it's like it's like you know what you
resist persists apparently and it just
keeps coming back to face us but but I
you know if he doesn't go well I do
expect him to change it up I don't
expect it to be a regular thing but who
knows maybe he'll maybe he'll find that
way he doesn't have the kind of lines
that scare him and he'll he'll be coming
back to the French wealth
yeah part of the reason I actually
really am high on was he so as French as
I remember back in the 2011 or 2009
World Cup this is throwback I almost
historical at this point though he beat
got a confit with the black on the black
side of a French and I remember being
very impressed way back then that
there's this guy just crushing God
accomplished when the best players in
the world on the black side of a French
and God is someone you'd expect to just
destroy a French based on the style yeah
and he made it made it a very
entertaining and fighting game and he
also beat Vasily Ivanka in the same
event on the black side if I'm not
mistaken you might even exchange French
even or something like that but he did
win those games I was just you know
really amazed by the way he plays in
here we see this position Oh from blacks
point of view you have more activity
than to some of the French's we saw
Georg modern play well yeah much more
right I mean this is a completely
different type of game than the advanced
attacks we were getting with a closed
position where white is just King
hunting from from the outset but the
tirage is not at least these variations
of the tirage right where the center
opens up this is not the type of line
that even if whites a whites a little
better now the kind of lines that
frighten black as far as checkmate
attacks right and we see that way he's
the one sitting here for a think and
this may become a theme in that he's
spending a lot of time in stages
not exactly critical moments I wouldn't
call this point in the game super
critical because you're thinking okay I
was gonna say Quidditch five and you
couldn't plays it of course you're
aiming for that King side trying to
deliver a checkmating attack and okay if
like Queen h4 now black inning sort of a
ignore the dark sports at the time being
thanks to the 995 so you can play me
like should be seven and then you should
consider Oh is white get us sometimes
sacrificing the e6 square is that
something scary that you need to worry
about and now I think that for the time
being like look I was saying earlier
that black has some activity the bishop
when the long diagonal deficiency five
hits this knight on d4 and I'm not too
concerned for was they at this point in
the game I really think he's comfortable
he he looks very focused on camera and
he has a lot of experience in these
lines and a4 is a good move always a
good decision challenge that pawn
structure in the Queen side and from
blacks point of view you say it's like a
five now or is it too soon right I do I
do I take on a four or played B for
myself these kind of decisions are
always very difficult to make and was he
as I mentioned being very experienced
he's gonna take on a for now if the rook
takes a four
he might play Queen b6 hitting B 2 in d4
he's got options Queen b6 hitting B 2
and before no he plays the move rook e8
but one thing that's funny is now that
he's really aggressively preparing he 5
if your wayi you almost want to waste a
move just to get your book back to
safety because rooks rooks on on loose
squares like this that's how bad things
happen everybody just use your
imagination that if this Queen was ever
able to come here and fork a square like
g2 along with the rook on a4 that's how
you make blunders so I like this move
Knight f3 mainly because I think the one
way the way you flips the script on that
idea and says all right I'm not gonna
retreat the rook I'm gonna try to
justify its existence and open up the
fourth-ranked suddenly there's actually
Queen age six and rook h4 on the docket
I know I know I've got mating on the
mind as you know but but - am I crazy
call me Shirley you if you're Queen h6
Bishop f8 will surely be the response
and so you can't get away with this
mating attack that you so desperately
seek but what about Knight d6 from black
hairy eye I think maybe six is always a
smart to kick this rook away hit them
they don't have three but now isn't
y-you just going ninety five is it
response 285 think that this is exactly
I didn't want this Knight entering the
action because black can with
withstanding an attack as long as there
aren't too many pieces coming into the
game and Aphrodite five I'm certainly
worry about throwing Knight you for
coming
yep how to deal with that I guess I can
try - I can't play f6 I lose a pawn I
can play Bishop a6 and pray that we
exchange bishops and that's one fewer
pieces you have to maybe with but I'm
starting a really like White's position
ya know it's interesting again I I think
we were feeling that and of course we we
almost jinx black saying that this is
not normally a type of French wear black
falls falls under a mating net but now
with white having a lot of pieces
potentially pouncing to the Kings side
way Yi's taken some time to try to come
up with out how to do it when ninety
five came into play oh there's just some
progress hitting the f7 square which is
is well protected from time being but
Knight g4 is definitely a temptation as
well as ideas just Bishop to h6 if you
play we're gonna bait so you can't
protect that square very well yeah and
you it is as nice as this Knight is you
you can't really ever move it without
weakening the f6 square or creating new
ways
for white to have attacks with the night
G for coming deaf sick so I'm starting
to have a hard time knowing what
defensive idea what Wesley might come up
with perhaps Bishop to f8 back to g7 is
something to consider here to make sure
that the in-laws don't stay too long for
dinner on the dark squares yeah bishop
f8 to g7 is something that actually is
somatic and these have positions you
have your holes right I got the cheese
on the kingside h6 f6 g7 all these
squares it kind of week so playing
Bishop a fade certainly makes sense I
think the problem here is if you play
Bishop f8 can I get away with we wish
your queen going higher rooks e4 I hate
your Queen away from the f7 square I
didn't want to sacrifice an f7 take on
h7 yeah that's crushing I like that I'm
going for the mate that you kind of put
in my mind I wasn't thinking checkmate
until you started talking about these
things whatever what else am I here for
right get you thinking about a mate
speaking of which how's the how's the
dating life by the way I have to back up
and just show if we want to talk about
fun mates that could have happened let's
say black played a move like Knight b6
we had Queen takes h7 King takes rook h4
followed by Bishop f6 so do your tactics
trainer everyone and no apparently yeah
no we would have been winning so your
tactics trainer and spot mating nets so
I like the sacrifice by was a so he
actually gave up the pawn on f6 yeah and
now we want rook f8 which hits the f2
pawn so he's getting his counter play in
if white plays rook f1 there might be a
problem the e5 square but actually if I
go after your knight if I go work e8 a
Queen d7 check which seems to save the
day for the time being although it does
it rook e8 deal Queen d7 I take take and
dive rook takes f2 there no then give
the Bishop retreated math once I know
unfortunately not made you on the back
rank thank you see her Bishop on the d3
squares and that wouldn't work out so 94
rook e8 so trading on i-80 see six at
the end hitting both rooks in the
diagonal oh this looks problematic for
so queen d700 GA check
what a shot 95 he wins the queen oh my
god so he won the queen because
unfortunately for Wesley he put his
Queen on d7 missing the night fork so he
took that fork on g8 there would have
been night of six check winning the
Queen and said he movies kena f7 95
check happened so unfortunately for was
they he missed Bishop c6 I think yeah
I'm not using an engine here but I think
Bishop c6 would have well picked up
material thanks to the Brooklyn EA tan
day for both being under attack instead
was the walks right into a fork and look
ghf of spotty instantly by way in no
reaction by the Chinese Grandmaster he
is just another play he's not here react
he's here to get victories stone-cold
killer you know and so oh we see this
line that I was looking just in the chat
for a second just seeing people you know
really freaking out at that great
tactical shot there but in this game we
see this King on e 2 and this line has
been weirdly popular as of late I think
was it Nakamura planted against his
white against a nice giri so this this
is not unfamiliar territory with FRA the
player here knowing again I it's it's
sort of what we predicted to start right
these guys are gonna play theory I think
that even if way you didn't impress us
with his prep versus the French last
game he clearly eventually knew what he
was doing in that position and and the
attack was slow building and and
executed well and now now we see them
going right back to theory again with
Wesley so challenging way in a very
topical line right now so I like it this
is gonna be one of those speed chess
matches that if you don't download your
Twix and keep your PG ends up to date
you might actually miss some interesting
critical games in some of these lines
yeah it's funny that we're talking about
you know theory or London system or the
whole point in the London seems to be
let me just get an opening for white and
not have to deal with any intense theory
I'll go slightly better positioned yep
but in this particular line clearly it's
very complicated what he's currently
sacrificed
right excuse me black a sacrifice apiece
points up a piece but this 96 is lost
because it's pinned to the Queen and a
fourth and so now g3 says please go
ahead take my knight and take my knight
with the Queen I'm happy to engage in a
queen trade put my bishop on g2 at some
point they play for efore that said this
is black knight come from f6 to d5 and
block that diagonal so it's not exactly
a tremendous advantage for white but
this move g3 does make a lot of sense
well wait you still I mean he has it
hasn't moved much and Wesley Wesley
turning to the side slightly I think
trying to hear the fans saying I say
make some you say noise right trying to
show his ear to the fans
no but Wei Yi is thinking clearly about
how he wants to handle this a big big
decision right now okay it keeps the
Queens on the board 95 you can take on
f4 and there's threats of c3 in some
positions so to me this is the this is
the you know the theoretically
challenging thing to try to do and say
yes King e2 is topical but it is a king
in the center and let me let me try to
take advantage of that thing so is white
gonna try to play some of these simply a
3-2 kick this Bishop away and if you go
Bishop e7 I'll go Queen takes t4 but I'm
not loving White's position because as
you just mentioned there's a king on e2
yep so even if white goes ahead and
tries to go off this c6 pawn double pawn
you still have a king on e2 it it's not
finding safety anytime soon yep so and
black might well it's interesting
because when you take c6 it's hard to
avoid trading Queens if I have to play
just a kind of a passive by Queen d8 but
you know let's say a black castles but
it is it is gonna be kind of a long term
dynamic question will black get enough
counter chances against the white king
here before all of these pawn weaknesses
on the Queen side start becoming an
issue because you highlighted it well
with the Queen's on or off the board the
c4 pawn the c6 pawn the c7 pawn none of
these none of these pawns are great so
White's goals are very simple here
everyone the rook H to c1
if I can castle by hand and put my King
on f1 who knows maybe make the whole
journey all the way to g1
White has the bishop Perrin is
positionally better so I like this move
way ease is trying to really challenge
the fact that when he wins back that
piece on c6 he's not just gonna be
positionally worse with a whole bunch of
bad pollens here yep and so I guess was
it does not know the theory particularly
deeply in this line
he knows obviously a ton of theory and
otherwise he's a great player it's not a
question of that but this particular
line I would guess the way you played it
knowing if you'd be more familiar with
it and so now okay you can take on c6 so
let's say rook takes c6 I guess if you
can take on c4 they're the Brooke yeah
it feels it feels a little dangerous to
have the Queen's I wonder if you take
with the rook if I could consider
grabbing the a5 pawn as as greedy as
that sounds because if I can safely tuck
the Queen back to a square like d2 and
then castle by hand I'm you know feeling
comfortable is white so but Dani when I
see a bishop on f4 with pawns an e3 and
g3 yeah I'm just waiting for the moment
g5 haha super nice point there Robert
yeah yeah no that's a shot that everyone
needs to keep their eyes open for and
now after Queen takes if you don't trade
Queens there's threats of Knight takes
f4 would check oh did he just miss that
yeah Knight takes e4 when's the big
support just wins the bishop on g2 what
does he have nothing okay i right as I
was highlighting it he blundered into it
so um strange decision there from Wesley
unless he shocks us with a super deep
sacrifice I think were safe to say we
have one of our first blunders of the
match yeah he he kind of shuffles in a
share there it gives a quick head nod
like ah that wasn't the best decision
yep bishop d8 here right just take care
of your back rank and it's hard for
whites make progress of just one Queen
on the attack
no and he and he hears you loud and
clear and this is we're about to
potentially see a two-game lead for the
underdog to start this match so calling
for a close one is what we did and right
now our our stats are actually looking a
little silly where ye leading leading
the way just don't Castle here right if
you Castle you're on the ranks of one
yeah something to keep an eye on rook
she want that's
that's a battery for those who keep
track of that kind of stuff
so how what's the easiest way to take
care of this make make up like queen g4
check or something like that and try to
get your king that's a nice move because
he's saying look you can't just go for
your attack
I have rook c2 coming and we'll see who
gets mated so so rook c6 is it's a way
to sort of threaten to castle for black
because now you could rook q1 wouldn't
work anymore because of maybe it would
actually I don't see one first and then
castle okay yeah yeah yeah this is
really well played by the way he is just
he knew the opening very well he's give
up with idea work a6 and was he was not
as familiar and it's backfiring yep so I
mean very impressive this far very very
impressed by way ye so I agree I'm a
little surprised I still I still expect
Wesley to be the favorite but who knows
just based on what we know about these
players right now we're just we're
seeing a really great play from the the
Chinese superstar who really came on
strong a few years ago right way II came
on as many people's call to challenge
the the throne of Magnus Carlsen at some
point he's kind of slowed down I guess
in terms of popularity and reached the
the woes of how do you go from 2750 up
right that's that's not an easy thing to
do but right now he's showing why people
touted him as such a talented person and
he's got a two-game lead Robert what are
your thoughts on Wei Yi and his
potential I think he's awesome he was
twenty seven fifty something I believe
it as his absolute peak yep and he's now
on twenty seven thirty but it's just you
know I couldn't tell you from experience
I've never been that highly rated but to
go from that twenty seven twenty to
twenty seven sixty that just seems
extraordinarily difficult we have seen
many players for example Roddick wait
our check is around twenty seven thirty
something and I think he has been at
but you often see him closer to twenty
seven thirty David Navarro similar boat
they are both incredibly talented
players whom I certainly look up to
their chest abilities but there's
something that keeps them from reaching
the level of Wesley so Hikaru Nakamura
right so yeah it's it's pretty difficult
apparently to
go higher than that and well for way
he's still very young perhaps he's still
kind of gathering his bearings and his
learning things about chess every single
day as we mentioned a little earlier he
lost his round against new Yankee today
or yesterday for in China in the
round-robin tournament so he's still
learning he's still growing and we'll
see if he can make that jump from twenty
seven thirty into the twenty seven
seventy range because he's still what is
he 21 or something yeah no he's still
super young so it'll be interesting to
see and obviously this is the first year
we've ever had him in the speech s
championship and probably probably won't
be the last so right now he's got a he's
got a Lopez that looks about as awkward
as you can get with the bishop on d2
instead of the night something tells me
that d5 is actually a really well time
shot by Wesley here Robert yeah
so we Queen takes have three pawn takes
no he goes d4 okay like because there's
a visual nd to an item b1 that can't
come out right now and if you play a
move like Bishop to g5 well if you do
mention overnight to d2 after Bishop c5
you always to consider detai see if
there could be takes d4 to give the
black knight that d4 square so that's
something to keep in mind there's a sort
of theme but what I just looked up is
what are you really 19 years old Wow
yeah okay you've been younger than I
thought he was and so it kind of goes to
show he's got that mature kind of like
I've been here before look on camera
right now but yeah he's uh he's he's a
he's a young pup yeah and in this game
he's got the white pieces he is met with
someone who's very experienced in these
lines and note it's important to note
that Wesley played you 45 this game you
don't want to get into a friendship and
you must not have enjoyed you know he
didn't lose that game but his opening
slightly worse after the opening stage
so he's deviating and I think we'll see
a lot of that from Wesley in the match
he seems to be someone who knows his
openings very well but is not afraid to
mix it up and right now for wait he he
was eating up clock Ernie o'clock he has
three minutes and eight seconds as far
as a minute half more than he he does
and right now you don't want to take on
d5 but
he took on c3d I don't think I love that
move necessarily I take with the bishop
on c3 and that way after Knight takes d5
pawn takes d5 you have to go make tea
for I think I take on d4 and I'm left
how do I feel about this now that now
I'm second-guessing how much I like this
but I thought that white would take over
the e-file and have a night against the
bishop and a favorable dynamic so sit
with the pawn on c3 and made my whole
point yeah he had to hold the d4 square
right but it still feels that ever since
black played d5 white is in a
less-than-ideal Lopez am I am i over
exaggerating importance of the fact that
black broke through with d5 on move 10
when when White's development wasn't
quite ready for the center to open yeah
I mean sometimes it's beneficial for
white but in this particular line
doesn't look to be the case because the
nighttime b1 is nowhere to go the bish 1
d2 is sort of stuck hanging on to the c3
pawn so even a move like rook to d8 here
either broken I believe is a decently
move because if white ever captures on
e5 you simply play 97 to regain that
pawn any played rook d8 it looks like a
good moving me and if you play d5 is
white I moved my queen from c6 and then
play pawn to c6 next move and that just
chisels at that white pawn Center yeah
it's not the size of the center it's how
you use it right if you can't hold it
down that it's just a target for black
to poke at for the rest of the game for
sure and right now it's certainly being
poked at the nighttime b1 is really
what's bothering me I'm someone who
likes to develop my pieces yep
and well nighttime b1 bish 1 d2 not
doing a great job of looking
particularly developed so what was the
theory here I know these guys have
played me in line but and I know I'm
going back to it because we're talking
about the strategic evolution of this
position being one where black broke
with d5 and now feels like he has them
much more active pieces and white is
struggling to get developed to protect
the center where did where did white
maybe go wrong on the analysis board
here back to this this move Bishop d2 is
a unique type of development in this
line right we see more traditional
Italian ideas like c3 to maintain the
flexibility of d4
she bring the night to D - maybe f1 and
you do you do the thing that we see a
lot of players do bring their nights
over to the Kings side so do you know
much about this line or why Wesley
recognized his opportunity to kind of
change the game here with d5 well so he
played d5 because well I don't really
know much of the Bishop d2 line I know
it is a played line but once c3 happens
now you play d5 because the pawn on d3
is a potential target right so he kind
of waits for the c3 push and then please
do you fob despite having played d6 2
knows Brier
so it's instructive stuff I think for
players who play the structure to see
how players of this level look for
opportunities weaknesses or created
things change and then you change the
center with it ok we're not calling the
game yet but I actually really like
Wesley to get his first win here I'm
liking why don't I put a piece on d3
double on the D file and yeah here he
goes I feels good about blacks chances
you know I can't do anything there's not
mb1
it's gonna be yeah it's been there the
light it's gonna be the reason why white
loses just rook to d1 now yep how was
this night expecting to get out any like
ever it's like ever like ever ever
forever ever forever ever ever
outcast reference we've ever had on the
show is that the first miss Jackson
reference of all time are you for real
oh and I'll just tell you I'm sorry miss
Jackson but alright
the yeah I agree and it seems sometimes
you can make these games seem as simple
as chess we always wanted it to be when
were we were young and teaching kids
like hey white had a neglected
development you know didn't choose the
most traditional or active development
schemes black opened the center and now
has had the initiative ever since C
threes week I look at night a for as I
move now but I don't even want to go
take that pawn if it means I'm helping
way you deal with this horrible night on
b1 right so what what plan do we develop
here that doesn't help the queenside I
think that actually gave me very
difficult is when you sacrifice a pawn
you oftentimes want to regain that pawns
it even the material as quickly as
possible and I was gonna say this move
h5 because you play h5
yeah ready to go h4 it and give your
King left you can play Knight a4 at any
moment it's like III pawned no suddenly
be well defended here yeah now I don't
even play 96 because now I go to F oh I
like that idea
Oh Robert
and dirty now look at this everyone
nights coming to f4 Queens going to g6
and watch out for for that tonight night
at 4:00 already just let's just do it
just do it because if you play a night
at 4:00 you know what is why trying to
do a play Bishop g3 to kick this night
out then I think I can just go Knight
takes h3 check yeah you might just go to
sac town and how does that work and I
have for Bishop g3 takes takes and queen
g6 no I'm not no Queen G I'm gonna go
Brooke takes f3 and if my other robot I
was gonna say Queen g6 because you can't
defend with the King because of idea uh
no never mind okay you're right you're
right just take up three I don't have
enough and they put my other rook on d3
and then just kind of mow down the
third-ranked okay we're gonna find out
if he if he feels the same way but seems
like black B creep in here
to the King side even Queen h6 is a
great move protecting that night if you
take on that for your dark scores are
horrible right so if you don't feel like
sacrificing play Queen h6 and just
defend that night let's look at night
takes h3 again Knight takes pawn takes
you like rook takes f3 let's all defend
and play devil's advocate I'll play
Bishop h2 what's the next move oh you
even have Queen C 5 and then rook up two
and looks like Bishop c5 one of those
something to c5 is happening we got a
queen c5 in the game you know I like
that decision by Wesley there everybody
that to not go all-in because your
opponent is down to 10 seconds right yep
I wasn't even looking at that now that
you mention it I seen 8.9 in the clock
and so it should be pretty
straightforward much much better for
black so no need to take any crazy risks
that could bob yards win the game no and
that that's the point we're making
everybody sometimes you have those
critical roads right your mate you're
making a decision at the fork in the
road but assess your opponent's
difficulty to defend it as much as
whether you really like an idea and here
keeping the pone white in the bad
structure that he's already been in
basically playing down a night in a rook
yeah just made it made it much easier
for the position to play itself the
easiest moves for your opponent to find
under time pressure are captures and
checks so don't go for a bunch of
captures and checks when your opponent
doesn't have any time to think
that's really good advice it makes it
much easier when you throw in captures
because with the increment that these
games are being played with yo can
actually restore some time when your
clock quite quickly if you would just
initiate a bunch of trades of course it
was a winning trade do it but don't just
trade for the sake of trading when your
corn is low on the clock
well we have a match Robert Wesley
strikes back and our predicted odds to
win the match still have Wesley so
higher right now you see that blue bar
creepin where it started around 69%
similar to where Levon Aronian was
favored against
Fabiana to start so that's that's what
we have at the score the actual score
graph that shows where they started only
a couple games in so all right well what
we'll keep our eye on that here we have
a our first kind of semi semi Catalan
here what is it said it's an English neo
Catalan I think for those who speak
matrix
well played there with that joke but you
know the idea from blacks point of view
is that with his early b5 yes you have
Bishop d7 in but you really want to play
for it eventually c5 now c5 is never
that easy to get in because when you do
play c5 jewelry with the b5 on so if you
played before is black will ignite to
worry about your pawns being
overextended on the queenside think it's
exactly what white wants if you up
before then my pieces of control the c-4
square there's still this backward pawn
on c6 so that's why a six is played so
it's c5 isn't it once again an option
now Defour if you go c5 too soon there
will be consequences with the Queen
staring down the c5 square and this is
the tension that goes on in these
openings with Wesley's present ne5
saying you're not getting c5 in thanks
my vision logic do your Bishop on b7 if
you keep trying to play for some pot
well maybe I can go efore myself game
more space in the center of course it
was castle and figure out the specifics
in a bit so okay 97 way sometimes you
can sacrifice the e pawn by 94 yeah five
I was just gonna say and the reason is
after 95 you have things like either
Knight c5 immediately or Bishop before
and then but this is an awkward position
for black to deal with the threats here
and not wanting to give up all the dark
squares yeah Bishop f4 is also a very
good-looking option castle so he's
giving up the pawn yeah I think it's a
good good decision especially because
way he has shown himself vulnerable to
time trouble early games yes yes ways up
two and half one and a half but his time
situation hasn't always been ideal of
playing in complicated positions so
Knight takes e5 I think could get him
into a world of trouble if there's the
simple bishop before as you had
mentioned earlier yep well for those of
you just joining us we had a little bit
more viewers come in recently remember
this is the 2018 speech chess
championship this is our third match of
the year and we've we've had some big
names already but this one is proving to
be one of the more exciting ones at
least at this point so don't go anywhere
and I wanted to tell everybody that have
an updated take on the on the score
graph there our fault there the that
looks a little more fun to see some
colors intermingling there like they're
dancing on the graph and of course
that's the actual score of the match
progression so far but we'll keep you up
to date given how much it's bouncing
around Wesley so starting out as a big
favorite and now things look to be about
even already way II was somebody who we
thought would do well in the the 5-1
portion yeah no he's clearly a talented
blitz player we I sort of expected it
simply because he's young and I just
thought that okay you're young you tend
to play more blitz so I was expecting
big things out of him at that time
control what I was sure about is his
bullet skills and what I got word of is
that he's been playing a lot on chess
calm in the last month clearly getting
ready for the match and he played 200
games this past month every single one
has been bullet and some have even been
one plus one which is the time for show
in this format so you clearly been
gearing up to play Wesley so in this
position really liking was these
position we talked about this idea
before night coming to e4 taking the c5
square under control the d6 square of
course if black plays c5 now hoping that
you know you can't take on c5 I do move
Knight to g5 very fanatical I was gonna
say Knight f6 check but I guess Knight
g5 is the more thematic no g5 Knight g5
mr. wins material because after Knight
g5 you stake with the bish one g5 I take
on b7 and you have a fish bunch e5
hanging your 97 is a problem so white
just simply goes up material there okay
very nice and Queen c7 doesn't help
because Bishop f4 you're still not
really wanting to take on eating five at
that night because then I think I can
just take on e5 lay rook d7 which is
another few Matic solution to
sacrificing this pawn for white so
Bishop f4 makes complete sense threatens
your idea with Knight f6 check so it
should before here is just good you know
a lot about the mattock ideas Robert you
know I've been trying you always make
fun of me for not knowing opening but I
do know you know I don't like the
members specific memorization the
acknowledge how important it is but some
of these ideas are very important to be
aware of and here is that look at the
7th right to the fish pump e7 and
ambition 1e 7 if the queen is not on c7
and the brook can get to d7 there are
two of them under attack here's Bishop
a4 cake plate and so now this Knight is
very ready to come the d6 square yes oh
people look the d8 or rook to e8 I can
just throw a knight in to d6 and black
is really just cramped the desperate for
some space and once this Knight does get
to DC Oh Knight f6 check this got a pin
lights out I mean I check is already
looking
yeah and in Wesley doesn't take much
time to go for it so as you've been
pointing out all the thematic ideas that
should have worked my idea only worked
because wayy blundered but hey Knight f6
check looks like a lot of fun you take
with discoveries that you're gonna take
on g7 and just blow open blacks King
here everybody yeah this is a
problematic cuz you have to move your
queen say to c8 to give you a bishop on
b7 protected and then just pawn things
g7 as you mentioned okay there's no
clear knockout blow quite yet you know
even if material were equal that the
control over the D file gives white a
huge plus anyway so that's why this
position is quite so bad for black use
take on g7
take on b7 go rip these six or rip d1
okay this doesn't help ya think you pick
on g7 first anyway any any Queen Queen
of five here's Queen a five but
immediately well I think the idea is
you're gonna take on TV yeah very nice
yeah
really strong everybody taking a four
loses a piece because of the skewer of
the Queen and Bishop and if you have to
protect the night
it means moves like and like you take on
d7 and then play Queen g5 right yes sir
yeah look at this everybody something
like rook to rook to d8 to garnet we
take on d7 no matter how UK up he's
gonna miss it Queen to g5 followed by
Queen age six nothing like you and I
predicting a mating net that comes to
fruition Robert it feels good ma'am
feels great feels great I was he is just
wait I might just resign on that one
yeah he does but that was a phenomenal
showing by Wesley it was a really poor I
don't say poor understanding of course
it's not about understanding it's just
for execution by way either he didn't
ever get them with c5 in like he wanted
I think was he choice play 95 I said in
the moment yep very good vision because
it keeps blacks sort of pass it from the
time being you don't get to c5 break
into open up your Bishop on b7 so you're
stuck with this kind of subpar Bishop
there and never got things quite going
so a good decision by Wesley to get back
into this match a two and a half two and
a half we started down two and a half to
half yeah I was gonna say Robert we're
45 minutes 45 minutes in / 45 minutes
left right right about the halfway mark
of the five-minute portion and how do
you feel Wesley respond to those first
two games right it feels like he really
came back here said I I need to wake up
a little bit myself even though it's
early for Wei Yi in China and we have a
match ladies and gentlemen yeah you know
I honestly wasn't that worried for was
it so early in the match and I'm
particularly curious with a bullet
portion as I tend to be because I'm less
familiar with how good these players
aren't in bullet but I think what was he
has going for him is he has this
strategic prowess not just over way Yi
but over most players in the world you
see him grind people down in these
positions where he is a nagging
edge and it's almost like where did I go
wrong yeah you know I lost a friend no
I'm just kidding very much very much
like Magnus Carlsen when when Wesley is
playing his best you know it's a very
mistake freestyle but kind of a nags at
the position as you said right and
slowly like your mother nagging and
nagging at you not you I meant like moms
in general that's what my mom is
watching this brother I didn't meet that
at all
Robert has never told me that you nagged
him okay that's not at all
she's definitely mad at you now she
knows I'm kidding you know I really
think was he as has that style yeah
where a game that comes to mind actually
is his win over Michael Adams I want to
say from the 2016 yeah London chess
classic where he just ground him down in
Catalan we're probably Adams didn't even
quite know where he went wrong I
certainly didn't when I first looked at
the game and it is a very impressive
style indeed now after pawn takes t5
miss game firstly way he's down a minute
on the clock already thinking of all
it's one of those positions where white
gains upon if you want to take on d5 but
you're gonna have some serious
repercussions by putting your Queen on
d5 so early I can play Bishop e6 I can
castle I can put a repent d8 all with
not all but most of these with in the
gain of a tempo yep and so white gets in
very big trouble that's why you tend not
to want to get too greedy in the opening
stage here a nice take on d5 I play
Bishop g2 as he as we just did
yeah and just castle get your king safe
and then deal with d5 in the future and
one of the questions for Wesley here is
is do you take advantage of the
opportunity to maybe look for something
like d4 where you can trade off that
isolated pawn before it becomes real
target he decides no so he's going into
a position where you're gonna have an
isolated Queen pawn on d5 and if way you
can can manage things like b3 Bishop b2
you sort of want to strangle the squares
around the pond so that it becomes truly
weak that's the strategy for white
against this pawn but look for Wesley to
maybe try to punch this move d4 through
before before way he has enough time to
do what I just said but there's there's
interesting shots here Robert things
like b4 start coming to mind things that
make
wonder if we will be really aggressive
to try to complete development and hold
the squares around the pond no before is
always an interesting idea with the
Queen on v6 yeah it is a pawn sacrifice
it to be very careful and think of the
consequences pretty deeply before doing
so if black does go d4 well now b4 is
probably moved that's going to be met
with because now I take attack the
Bishop on c5 which in turns attacks
between on b6 sort of hanging pieces so
a big trade like this would probably be
just fine for uh for white everybody
that's the point so yeah so yeah Wesley
decides he agrees and doesn't want to
risk that b4 coming with tempo backs
that thing up but now okay so now this
Bishop e7 is a it's no mistake he went
to that Square no else because if b4
comes black will play Bishop f6 and
probably still look to punch the move d4
through so how does Wei Yi coordinate to
surround this week d5 pawn now do you do
you play Knight d4 even though it might
just be a big trade and we're both of us
end up with isolated pawns d4 well view
a 94 the problem is the b2 pawn from
what you know boys point of view so if
you play 94 black we'll just play Bishop
f6 and uh I don't want to activate your
Bishop on c1 which is a very good idea
that you're coming up with from White's
point of view that Bishop would love to
break free yeah but instead it's seem
yet 94 would be your right Bishop f6 and
so that means well you have to cope with
something a little more creative okay
he's gonna risk it place before I don't
like this because I don't like it at all
cuz this is exactly what we just kind of
foreshadow I mean d4 will be the natural
follow up and if the position opens up
usually the person who had the isolated
queen pawn everybody is the one with
more active pieces so because generally
that's something that comes with an
isolated pawn is a slight lead
development usually slightly more active
minor pieces if that's not the case then
probably you just have a bad isolated
pawn position but but here this is
looking more and more dangerous and I
and I do expect the position open up in
favor of black yes see how do we
continue opening the position for Nellie
you play d4 I'm wondering if white is
gonna play E for in response no
No okay maybe you're right but I do love
d4 anyway I feel like this is exactly
this is thematic how you play with an
isolated pawn here everybody and try to
use your activity here before white can
surround it alright but he plays your
move so we'll see we'll see he's good
this is good for black yeah this pawn on
d4 is it may still be isolated but now
she's a passer right she wants to be a
girl
she's got dreams and it's also a lot of
weak squares on the Queen side many many
weak squares so there's c4 there's b5
the a3 pawn is a potential target of e3
half and bishops get traded black can
consider playing a5 himself I know
Bishop a2 to kick the rook off the B
file then yeah that could be a nice
little shot yeah that way you got a 5
and the bishop on b2 is not protected so
yep and pin to the pin to the bishop the
opponent before would be so now there's
there's even little little tricky tempos
right Bishop 8 to kick the rook then go
back to c4 hit the other rook and then
play a 5 okay there's throwing out ideas
and lines to try to use Roberts really
important idea of playing a move like a5
to undermine the Queen side pawns but
you know what Oh Wesley has other
tactics he wants the c-4 square for the
pony yeah because the bishop takes d4
simply Knight c4 then you take on b6 ago
rook takes d2 you have a fish 1 b6 and a
knight NC 2 okay hanging so that would
win a piece for blacks I just say I love
when you calculate you know I enjoy
calculating when it's not my pieces
because it makes me emotional a lot
easier to be a little a little bit more
loose when it's it's not your own pieces
yeah but again weigh you down on time
and so something we kind of foreshadow
to start he's been the one behind on the
clock and even though he jumped out with
two wins for those of you who may have
come late Wesley so has won the last two
games to be in this deadlock at two and
a half apiece but feels like Wesley
might be getting his third win in a row
here in a moment if he can figure out
the right way to use this strong pawn
and the super awesome activity this is
an isolated Queen pond like nightmare I
had once I think like if some reason
like Bab Buren was playing the other
side Robert and I blacked out
I mean this also 13 seconds left for
weight I didn't look at the clock yeah
no this is this is time pressure and and
D problems yep what where's the knockout
blow that that's I'm trying to figure
out because if I'm black the first thing
I think about is a queen ID to King on
coupon
should I go Bishop h3 to trade off the
light squared bishop Oh such a nice
little shot bishop h3 overwhelms the
light squares everybody and look at the
f3 square for the knight for account
motes I'm sort of looking at that but
I'm like well what if what ignores it
and then trade the bish Bungie to just
actually help black so then I start
thinking well I was gonna say the Bishop
c4 does that move better because I have
a d3 square to use if you have rook d1
I know either Knight d3 now or me Bishop
b3 there we go just patiently squeezing
the position everybody because it's a
lot harder for white to keep playing
this sort of cramps that have been it is
to go for some forcing line this is a
really important practical sort of
instructive lesson that Wesley's putting
on here using its time wisely he doesn't
want to play move like d3 okay if you
find a win wins are all that matters but
if not you'd rather play tickled with
the position while your opponent has
very little time on the clock then then
change it drastically okay right as I
say that he must have calculated
something concrete because now he's
playing instantly he's gonna play Knight
to c4 if Queen to d2 and that actually
looks like very straightforward here so
now Knight g4 hit f2 game over yep
boomtown f2 is a problem and so is the
clock and so is the clock tick tock
right way Yi is gotta be feeling a
little bit of pain there right jumped
out to a good start and now now the
American is flexing his muscles so time
to attempt to strike back
did you see was he leaned back there and
yeah no no he leaned he leaned back he
leaned back he did not do the Rockaway
though but now you take a huge sigh of
relief Wesley knows the Rockaway
over/under on chances Wesley knows the
Rockaway probably I'm thinking 20% okay
that's super generous in my mind I'd put
it at negative 2
if you said Rockaway he'd be like you
mean my rocking chair
[Laughter]
you know I don't know so I just had to
threaten Wes he's a sweetheart
does it you know I don't know that he
listens to too would you that's not even
like our generation that that stuff but
no okay here we go more theory yes more
theorist the b7 okay this Queen D to
remove I was about to mention it it
looks very strange because you block in
your own Bishop on the see one square
but you do get the two bishops very
quickly so as you see from whites point
of view you have this Bishop on g2 on a
post yeah you can bring this Bishop to
b2 and they pose b3 to do that yep and
from blacks point of view you're saying
well I am a little bit down in space
once Bishop b2 happens my c5 pawn can
become a target so do I play moves I've
rook d8 plate and how do I continue
because where is blacks counter play
gonna come from anybody Bishop b2 there
are no good discoveries 297 you can play
and move like Knight f6 will just want
Queen back to say c2 and that's not a
big deal not 296 is a bad move I'm just
trying to emphasize that these night
maneuvers aren't in the world I like
Knight b6 because now black plays c4 and
just as I was talking about where is my
activity coming from you find a new idea
c4 trying to take on b3 then when I go
94 I have a clear target you gain more
more space here I think c4 makes some
sense maybe seems a little rushed at
this moment yeah something that I like
to keep in mind is this move on c4
yeah and you made a great point about
the the Queen d3 being awkward if we
back up and try to learn something here
in the slower time controls the analysis
Robert said out for Queen d3 to make
sure you get the bishop here on d7 and
note that black really wasn't in a
position to try to trade Queens there
white would actually capture on d7 maybe
in a lot of positions and double the
pawns on the C file so sometimes you
lose a little bit of time to get a
long-term position allege like the
bishop pair and even though it feels
like White has to lose some Tempe with
the Queen okay and now way use doing the
right thing to take advantage of it the
time that white lost there he's trying
to say I'm not gonna let you get the C
file and gang up on this this C pawn I'm
gonna trade it off before you can so
okay I like this move c4 by way you but
it is definitely a position to note that
if it keeps becoming open
look for the bishop pair in this light
square bishop to be really strong yep so
I like to see four it's very good movie
just gives ya black some more
flexibility of another target and the b3
squared so what should white do now in
response yeah I was gonna say 94 I want
to open up my bishop but I was bored I
just f5 and everything that's aggressive
well the reason I still want your knight
their Queen c3 at some point seems quite
bothersome well I could play Queen c3 on
f5 but I guess you say you have bishop
f8 do i but then maybe I thank you I've
night before there
ah that's key because if you move the
bishop I would have put the night on g5
or even f6 but 94 is super strong
threatening the four key mode to spam
twitch so yeah okay but he goes for it
at 5 and 93 the problem with f5 is the
drop in the huge drawback of the e6 pawn
yep can become a potential weakness but
the Queen on c8 you're well positioned
to deal with it and now actually black
can consider playing 'if I've in the
future I wouldn't do that with my fish
106 I don't want to cede control to the
d5 square and so hmm I worry more about
the light squares in the long term f5 is
obviously it was a nice move to gain the
initiative you game one tempo and
essentially 2 moves on the previous
position but but now after I like rook
e1 by Wesley if he can slowly open the
position maybe play d3 try to just
create avenues against not just the e
pawn but eventually the the King on the
light squares there's 19 for win upon 90
for Queen to be won
ah you just take b3 yeah then I guess
white goes III but I can go take on a 2
with actually that's the kind of thing
that white wants to do yeah it was
actually give up the pawn there he gains
bishops and lines for the rook so I'm
now questioning that decision if you're
94 Queen B 1 e 3 I'm sorry C takes b3
then e3 pawn takes a to Knight takes a
to my bishop will take on f6 once you
move to right away and then I have this
Bishop on g2 still looking very strong
at an item b6 and c6 below them camera
they move particularly well so
certainly an option but really have to
think about the cons when he goes from
94 so yep he's trying to win that pawn
okay was that good the line we just
talked about exactly what I said is
about to happen and now the questions
from blacks point of view because I was
saying I don't really like the
consequences as a pony to good black of
his retreated with knight c6 and say I'm
not giving up my bishop when we have six
square instead I'm going to leave you
with this weird-looking pawn on b3 and
try to take advantage of that but yeah
but I wonder if knight c6 was played
maybe white would have just played d4
just sack the pawn like you said tried
to open the position and had a big
center so yeah you might be right there
so G takes f6 so now
Wesley has to prove the compensation
there is definitely potential here we
talked about the king being weak on the
light squares but now he may be weak for
other reasons
but to pass pawns are better than one
over here I mean the long-term potential
at black and Perry White's threats you
gotta like those pass pawns yeah but I
do like what you were just mentioning
you know d4 you know II fool ya if you
only want to play e4 here before you
look really good if it black takes the
knight comes in immediately with
concrete threats yeah I'm concerned yeah
about way he's position here because he
for you know you really don't want to
take on e4 yeah I love it he and he
plays it Wesley feeling a little more
relaxed like he like he kind of got
jarred jarred by the by the start of the
match and now has really seemed to find
his stride as many fans have been
pointing out in both the chest TV in
twitch chat we've yeah we've got
problems here after e4 if you're black
and I what I'd like to see again if I'm
a fan of Wesley so his look at the time
situation to go minutes in 49 seconds
two and a half for Hawaii that's just
really time and time again we're seeing
that it was he's getting ahead in the
clock and it's coming back to bite where
you this is a tough position I don't
think indefensible but it is a tough
position from blacks point of view
White's King is very safe
yeah blacks
while still safe for the time being what
am I thinking in my head I'm thinking
well if I take only four I can't really
do that because Knight takes e4 then
after a night eat a d5 to protect f6
yeah that might come to c5 my East six
pawn is weak and I hate square as a
vulnerable and say it plays rook c8
saying okay I'm attacked your knight and
c3 but what happens up to say Queen to
b3 or rook to d3 or one of these type of
moves where white can is the quiet I
think one interesting shot
might be look maybe an exchange sac
right I as you said that what what is
the answer I was wondering okay
something like Queen b3 if I if I
actually took on c3 and took on e4 okay
I'm down the exchange but I do have a
couple pass pawns and maybe can safely
establish a knight on d5 I would say we
should keep an eye out for a defensive
sacrifice here by black at some point I
kind of yeah that's a very interesting
idea I actually like the move he played
King I do too because the threat might
be f4 in some positions right d fine wow
this is gonna get sharp so you can if
you take on d5 then why'd you take back
with them on that pawns not really going
anywhere for the time being all those
bonds man feels yeah exactly the ugly
double F pawns but if you play e5 oh wow
five I didn't like that either so he
does this and brings them but d6 you
have to play d6 play with the inertia
here now 95 keep going the threat was b7
everybody which is why the knight had to
go there to c6 and now you're saying
Knight d5
yeah plant you got to play with the
initiative right now yeah because it's
like Queen takes d6 after 95 I can go
like I move my knight so Knight b6 seems
to win material cuz your Queen d6 is
hanging but also I was thinking I can
just take your b7 pawn as well and that
helps my bishop when they open diagonal
so you can't get away
f4 he decided he didn't like the e5
square being accessible to both nights
and it is a much slower approach but
it's not a bad one right because yes
white is down a pawn here still if we're
counting material but this d6 pawn is
better than both both the B and a pawns
and and it's and keeping blacks pieces
from coordinating on e5 I kind of
for a more again and you know what it is
Wesley seems to be very mature in his
approach right now recognizing the
writing on the wall way he's about to
get under 30 seconds again and he
doesn't want to make it too crazy if he
can if he can just keep the grind as is
okay I say all that in defense of
Wesley's a4 idea but honestly after
winning that pawn in Elric d8 with no
night discovery because of the check
that would have been on c5 I don't like
us at all for white right yeah you did
escape that check on c5 but now I'm
thinking rookie to take this bish bungee
to not right now but you mention
exchange sac so now it's in my planted
in my head this Bishop on g2 I wouldn't
want to take it off the board Knight b6
interest I'll look after the d1 probably
but now I see back rank issues in the e1
square so if you have rook ft1 I take on
d5 you take look there's gonna be some
way for white to still do the tactics
right just cuz blacks blacks position
just seems like such a positional wreck
but you're right I agree I mean f4 has
unintended problems here now right so I
don't love my p6 I felt like black could
have been a little bit more ambitious
but made him wrong and I actually I
guess it makes some sense I'm worried
though even if I trade all these nights
on the d5 square and then we trade all
the rooks that the Queen and Bishop will
be very good an endgame because the
double F pawns yeah so I'm kind of
thinking that black is gonna lose this
a7 pawn but perhaps just a way to save
it here can Oh Queen e6 absolutely queen
of favor that hunt the 96 still holding
despite only 18 seconds he's he's
finding all the right moves
so Brooke takes d8 here yeah Brooke
takes d8 Brooke c1 quickly enough
wait lay back rank problems Queen e2
right to hit the background all Queen e2
would have been a super tricky move
everybody threatening rook d1 he still
got it though yeah just play Queen e2
okay he's trying to defend and he's low
on time but right I thought you wanted
to get a little more active here because
I think long-term
he's prep is a problem with the pollen
f5 and f6 so yeah
mm-hmm okay this is a good defensive
setup though what you really want to do
is black is trade off all the heavy
material because why tonight should be
able to hold just fine against the
bishop as long as there's no threats
like it gets the black King or if the
Queen and Bishop can't work together for
some sort of battery oh no I don't like
that because at the end and the reason
why this is bad Danny is the pawn f5 is
gonna be lost you think or is it or have
97 and then rookie for he does rookie
six yeah he just looks like he may be
able to hold but he's you know right now
moves King up seven what's his okay I
liked age three
here comes g4 I would maybe play it
anyway even if they have four Paul is
hanging but okay he's building it up so
if he takes so how is why can win this
would unify maybe I like that knows
we've rook forever age six good move and
he's gonna draw that's a forceful way to
get the draw there if you were black and
didn't want to just sit there with the
double deth phones really this works out
that was a that was a impressive
transition by way ye I thought he's
gonna king g6 there it's a rookie six
back and I would King g6
not now not now but yes yeah no I agree
with you everybody defends each other
the night the rook one ten seconds from
just a movie only he's about to lose on
time that's a great chef queen a1 check
to try to flag your opponent yeah not
expecting that one king of 809 g6 check
this guy g6 racing back pre move that
there's a g6 back shouldn't be a draw
right he's gonna he's gonna flag seems
like he's gonna flag agree King g7 oh
it's it's gonna happen the flag is gonna
happen this is a little reminiscent of
Hikaru I think there's a little bit of
lag too so it's like yeah he's he's
clearly not on the best connection you
can see he's got two bars there where ye
unfortunately not rookie seven
seven well it's just a draw oh he's
gonna flag him he cut off the
second-ranked rugby seven just go I
think he's okay because I think you can
just put the rook on e6 and g6 and just
sit tight
there's just no there's wait okay now
now that he's pushed g6 Wesley is trying
to create mating traps with the Queen
flip seven he got him he got him oh he
got him overwhelmed the knight and rook
oh my gosh Wow
that was epic that was epic and I mean I
was just caught off guard there because
yeah you know it looked like way he was
defending very well and he really should
have won for that Queen e2 I've worked
he won backlink stuff he wouldn't have
been as much trouble he went for the
Queen sack which I think in a classical
game he was the right decision but like
we've talked about it so many times in
this format just how hard it is to
continue to coordinate pieces when
you're living off the increment where's
the Queen it's like she can do no wrong
right the Queen just makes moves that
are trying to trick you into into pre
moving and then losing time and very
difficult to defend those situations
with the pieces versus the Queen that
Queen a1 check move was so it was nice
yeah you get to the point where you just
want to make subtle Queen moves to try
to get your opponent when they're living
off the increment to to fail with a pre
move pre move fail right and you know
kind of words of advice for players who
may not be experienced in bullet-time
controls yeah for example when that
Queen a1 check happened the King moved
to f7 move that Queen to b2 is really
smart because yeah only maybe moving
back to that diagonal think you're gonna
give him Oh check that's what I was kind
of suggesting maybe more subtle moves
like that eventually it worked out for
Wesley right but I think the practical
takeaway is that with a limited
experience in this format I think
sometimes players make the right chest
decision which we saw Yvonne do this
against hey Cara would sack in the Queen
for two rooks right and you and I sort
of said very quickly like hey that's a
really tough thing to take on when
you're already under 10 seconds even if
it is the right chest decision yep so
okay
Wesley's field encounter though look at
the kitchen right he's checking on the
cat behind him yeah it all looks good
over there yeah
it is how does position look though you
know from first glance I think white is
in danger of becoming overextended
that's what I see the position with a
bish on b7 hitting the e4 square yep I
see on f4 if you ever got f5 and you
permanently give black that a five
square not yet happy loves it so I'm
trying to figure out how blac maneuvers
here Bishop f6 comes to mind but I don't
really like bringing my bishop on that
squared rather have my knight there and
also a bishop on f6 may run into an
eventual shot like five I guess not for
the near future but alright played
Bishop whoops legs
I guess Knight a5 is another option just
gaining more space with your pieces okay
can you go bishop d5 as well if Bishop
e5 would be a positional move everyone
trying to create a little little
surgical entryway on the light squares
over here on the Queen side which is
okay it's not the flashiest but way he
decides he likes it as well I actually
really liked that move yeah this is
gonna be a tough thing for Wesley to
deal with over here on the on the c6
square and the b4 pawn is also
potentially weak right and it has it
sort of almost Sicilian like feel to
yeah like I got bad night or for black
yeah except there's a pawn on c7 instead
I mean that exactly so the issue for
black is that if you took on d5 you have
this backwards c6 pawn you don't get
your typical counter play along the C
file so here does white just leave the
tension or do you put knight c6
immediately anybody's knight c6 the
point being if you take on c6 and get
the two bishops and that could be very
problematic yep rook and there may even
be immediate threats to follow that
Robert like II 5 because the d6 pawn is
pinned to the night oh yeah
so here rookie and I guess makes sense
just to stop e5 c5 but then be
forcefully I mean you are either huh
aren't you either taking or playing a5
to stop taking them before honestly I
don't even think about before I thought
already 5 and then that worried me yeah
which is also very strong you're right
so you might be right but a5 you
if I'm being met immediately by e5 that
seems seems serious tough yeah
especially because as we highlighted the
D pawn is sort of indirectly pinned
everybody to the undefended night on d7
but you're right though I mean if you go
rook e8 just Knight takes before I just
honestly the nemeth to see the pawn was
hanging so that looks good this is this
is a potentially big moment everybody we
just crossed under the 20 minute mark in
the 5 minute portion and Wei Yi as as
they say to use a term that's overused
and she is to stop the bleeding right
after after being up two and a half to 0
and a half of those just joining us
Wesley so has taken the last four
decisive games and Wei Yi needs needs a
win needs a win like like last game he
needs a win yep and that would cut his
deficit in half from two games to one
and he's very much in this match he he
jumped out to a very impressive start
and be always shocked even himself
I don't think ye who we talked to Wesley
before the match was he remembered six
games and he played against way yeah I
think he'd won two of those six and way
he had never beaten him yeah he probably
shocked himself just be like wow I'm
crushing Wesley so one of the brain
crush
beating him one of the best players in
the world and now he's settling into the
match he lost a bunch of games and he
was the first time he's actually up on
time where Yi was ready for this move
immediately captures on before he's uh
he's gobbled up maybe trades on b7 but
the idea everyone is that Wesley might
have tricks like takes b7 Queen takes
you can't just play 95 maybe because
there's targets on B 2 although okay
even that feels like should be pretty
dangerous for black to take me to
whenever you got a king exposed on a
diagonal like this you'd have to watch
out for weird tactics along the g1 a7
diagonal and I'm wondering when does 'if
I've come in to play this do it now but
I still give you a weak pawn to attack
so I play e5 and take it this Pony if I
might be vulnerable I thought you were
gonna say I'm wondering when the alarms
will ever stop in New York and then
realize there was no answer
so you moved on yeah absolutely no
answer to that question
we live in a hustling and bustling city
out here in York City just got a can I
hope they've got a little alright okay
so if I did happen yo like I shouldn't
be concerned was Pawnee five I want to
play b3 and just put the bishop on b2
and and and happily secure my extra
pawns
maybe I play King h1 Oh maybe none of
that happens wait he wants the whole
thing
e6 he's just gonna take e6 and blow this
baby open I wonder if he is gonna take
hers leave the weakness okay he does
answer that question immediately by
capturing there's no Bishop c5 check
yeah they take with my knight on c5 I
actually default everybody mean and
protect my my work on e6 that yet worked
so mmm
actually he seems to work out very well
because this bishop on c1 can come out
say to g5 and then in your future it
also can just sit on t2 perfectly happy
on d2 hitting the pawn on e5 it's a
position that feels a little anti
karpova in right when you've got the
King potentially open to tactics you've
got some pieces undeveloped so it makes
you a little worried in blitz that that
that there's some potential resources
for black but it feels like with
accurate play why shouldn't white just
be able to hold on to the healthy pawn
maybe now you can't even play Queen e2
just to overprotect you know Queen e2
you hit the rook on the aged and you
protect that okay Queen Queen e1 1 same
idea spying on the a5 on even now you
take take on 85 that was really smart
that was that was sassy even you know
it's Queen e2 so much more natural
because you want to get I would have
played Queen e2 with that we both
highlighted it you were saying it I was
piloting it but way ye he takes it to
the next level with Queen e1 that's
actually awesome yeah that may be my
favorite move in the match this flower
Queen one I just is smart you're doing
the same thing as Queen e2 but you have
a new target on the a file and in doing
so well that Queen's gonna remove
herself from a 5 then you're gonna go a
5 a 6 and that's a passed pawn out there
Queen f5 can be played Knight g5 check
ideas Bishop g5 here don't play Knight
g5 check because now after Bishop takes
g5 g 2 is a
bit of an issue so I think Bishop g5
just developed the final piece and now
if you take on g5 we'll take with my
night with a check that looks pretty
good
what else can you do here
Bishop g5 is what speaks to me yeah
Bishop g5 makes a lot of sense I feel
like he's probably just double-checking
tactics right now well work takes g2 is
a big threat yeah so that's why like for
72 you have anything now
did he just miss this
I was just highlighting looked into how
is it how is it not just crushing so I
think rook G 2 Kings u29 m4 a nice for a
king f1 Queen takes f3 check and then I
block with my queen I think at least you
can meet Queen h1 with Kimi too but from
my perspective and we're gonna see that
on the board it seems like such an
unshakable optimism an it being a plan
he completely missed I think you have
your king oh that can't be good no
tactics d4 Knight of 3 king f2 Bishop g4
9 f3 king of 192 h2 wait a second Oh
before immediately what a nasty move and
Wesley just smiles and leans back oh my
gosh it's so funny when you see top
grandmasters just act like little kids
he's just like so happy that he saved
that game and what a heartbreaker
therefore wayy because we had just
talked about what it needed win was what
how much he needed that win now it's
five games in a row for so and he was
just up a couple points but he just
missed rook takes g2 straight up yeah
that was shocking honestly I did not
expect way each and he's a quite a
strong tactical player I didn't expect
him in such a great position to me what
is at his level very elementary tactic I
mean I was saying look at that as a
queen on that diagonal if you take the
pawns YouTube this night or check stuff
and he just really overlooked it and
well that Bishop g4 check was a
beautiful finish yeah Bishop c4 check is
is almost a like it's
probably not a tactics trainer problem
right because it there were maybe
multiple ways to win but that was a
pretty nice solution yeah that was
phenomenal
yeah you don't see tight so that
frequently where you could just take a
night in f3 for a check and for free and
say you know go push up to d4 and give
up a piece for free because you're
getting at least a queen core mate well
now is where it really gets challenging
for Wei Yi right because he's he he
jumped out to a lead wesley wins four in
a row Robert but then then he has that
game that seems to be on pace to stop
the bleeding he's been better with white
we were just sort of talking about
Queenie one being the move of the match
and great technique and then and you
blundered away and one thing that
players who haven't played this format
don't experience until they play it is
right now if you lost that game and you
had a rest day you had some time you
could emotionally you know you go to the
hotel room you cry it out you turn on a
romantic comedy you let things go right
hey you don't have time to do that here
Robert I know you liked yourself some
some rom-com but he's got to shake it
off fast so what do you tell him did to
just forget about it and play the next
game it's very difficult to forget about
something that just happened when you
have you know seconds not even the games
next thing starts immediately so yeah
it's very hard to get over a game like
that especially when you were talking
about cut the deficit in half two games
to one now it's up to three games you
know you say I'm Glen Wesley so how in
the world am I gonna go plus three
against in the rest away right it's not
exactly easy to figure out and I want to
give a shout out to where is this
comment man in the suitcase says so
getting revenge for yi beating his
youngest to 2600 record that's a great
reference there a historic that's that's
a chess fan right there that's knowledge
knowing that Wei Yi beat Wesley cells
record for the youngest ever to reach
2600 feet a nice yep that's somebody get
that guy a diamond membership seriously
that's that's a 1-month diamond
membership let's get that guy a
membership man in a suitcase on Twitch
man suitcase on Twitch man in box that
though that's the story of my other life
okay
g5 here we go
Wesley thinking for a rare a rare amount
at given the openings that he's played
so far he seems to have been in control
but Chuck really took his time there
before making that decision yep and he
decided to take on d5 which I think
blacks supposed to well I was gonna say
Bishop before or Knight takes d5 you
can't go pawn takes d5 but moving g5
coming to kick your night out so Bishop
before is nice and said after D takes c6
do I have Bishop takes c3 or do I just
cat I just Castle you know what would be
fun yeah if he just okay he takes c3 but
I'm looking at your move castles on the
analysis board and just to show
everybody Roberts points there's just
nowhere for this King to go long term
and as the position opens up you're
gonna see all kinds of good tactics for
black but maybe way you gets enough with
Bishop takes c3 Queen takes in and now
castling cuz you still have a problem
with your King on f2 the emperor has no
clothes you can't take on a1 because ii
take steps i've been checked
king takes f7 Bishop c4 check your king
goes on dark score at Bishop a3 check
winning the Queen on a1 so don't get
greedy
don't take this rook on a1 you know it's
one of those things actually to come
sort of second nature to players like
Wesley so and you know what years well
he's not gonna take this rook on a1 he
was chuckling do I take on e6 or castle
right away but take on anyone simply
loses material and that's why he decided
to shuffle is came over to but it feels
it feels good for black I mean despite
thee I guess currently white is up upon
in the position and likely will remain
so if he takes f7 but from a practical
perspective I would much rather be black
here oh absolutely there's a king on f2
yeah you can play pawn takes east six
now to open the F file you can play
knight c6 it can continue playing with
the initiative the whole point of knight
c6 is while I'm waiting for bike to go
take on f7 so that opens my rook up
which perhaps the sacrifices so I think
knight c6 is have been moved in nice and
six feels feels good unlike unlike
playing with your food you should play
with the initiative so that's it that's
the two lessons Robert got don't play
with your food but play with the
initiative and I think there's no reason
to make an ugly kind of slow move get
the pawn back and I expect ye to do what
you said play with the
should've quickly get developed and keep
the pressure on so let's see he's
thinking and he's now down a little bit
of time on the clock but what I do think
about positions like this with
temporarily when white is up upon from
blacks point of view I think it's easier
to play your King is safer and that's
the Bliss is having the King safety is
very valuable because it makes it helps
you move more quickly while your
opponent has to think at every moment
oh it's Knight takes d4 sacrifices can
get me made it or something like that so
knight c6 here I would have played that
a while ago it might not be the best
move maybe haunte c6 is better yeah I
mean as much as I said play with the
initiative and I see six was the way to
do it I was just about to highlight that
taking e6 is also playing with the
initiative mainly because of the
immediate threat of a five right Robert
I mean when you play u5 you're
dislodging the knight and note that
white can't ever capture without
immediately devastating discover checks
so actually taking a6 may have been the
most accurate way to keep pressure
because of the threat coming now with
pony 5 yeah actually you just right I'm
so in the mood of like used Castle to
give a pawn there keep giving that pawn
on f7 so allow yourself to take with
rook takes f7 but I agree with you
actually that after pony six here comes
e5 where is white gonna go I would play
rook b3 because I need another defender
for my king
am I playing rook b3 I'm attacking your
queen yep my rook can swing over the
king side I still don't like my position
after rook b3 said Queen c7 right you're
still trying o e five but in s play
Brooke buddy though he does agree with
you you
yeah e fives coming very quickly I would
go king g2 from for her look f1 didn t v
e5 I wonder if he plans to take it and
call blacks Bluff now now that he's
gotten the potential development you
might see lines like a five takes with
check and that feels real good to get a
double check but now what and suddenly
White's pieces are flipping the script
over here to the Kings side this is this
could actually like backfire quickly way
he's not careful because of all the lack
of development for blacks pieces so so
III think if he five comes I think he
just takes it shocking
I agree with you now that I mean that's
some move that I'm not playing yep no
very simply because it's it's dope it's
double discovered check
that's why cuz you're cuz you're a human
being it's funny I actually was just
reading a chapter in a grits book the
how to play practical defense and I
remember a comment made that said that
today's modern-day Grand Master is just
much more willing to to just laugh in
the face of danger right they just don't
dismiss variations because of Dumbledore
discovered checks things that we
consider to be the power moves of chess
right you just can't allow it
and I think engines have taught us to
look deeper and that we know the more
people have studied with computers and
we see hey I can play the most dangerous
line here and really challenge my
opponent and that might pay off for
Wesley because now look at the time and
wayy a little irritated that he couldn't
just play e5 and anyway a guard Eggers
books are very good but I remembered at
that point very well that it may it's
something that comes up a lot I think
when you see guys like Magnus and Wesley
so play chess you know that's a great
point and you know and now you played
knight c6 which is a move I want to play
earlier the big difference is didn't
white just get the move rook b3 and rook
f1 in for like yep with Tempe baby yeah
so it's like now your attack of stole
but I think black still has a very good
counter play here the material is even
White's real benefit here is having two
bishops but there's a problem you have
Foursquare I can play b5 Bishop d7 and
you may have some trouble on diagonal
flex still really looking quite decent
here so now Queen before sacrifices at
the time the time the lack of
improvement in the attack just gets me
forward I love Queen d4 I love the
bishop coming to be to notice he was
just again laughing in the face of
danger of c2 he's feeling his practical
pressure right now Wesley is I think if
Queen takes he'll put the King on g3 and
he just sensed his opportunity to kind
of turn the initiative around much very
similar returning to beat around Oh
classic classic I brought you home with
that glorious stuff on a resume
so Brooke f7 so eventually when a double
rooks in the F file right yet in the F
there should be seven rook f8 but I'm
liking Wesley's chances more more just
whoa that move surprised me
I thought you know f5 to undermine the
protection than that in d5 yeah I agree
with you especially cuz it's the first
time we've seen Wesley go against what
I've been sort of a no you know sort of
appreciating that he hasn't played the
most forcing move on his opponent under
time pressure that seems like a kind of
an easy way to give black an easy
position now with obstacle bishops I'm
surprised by that so h5 gives Kings and
loved I would take in pied Bishop e7
rook c8 quickly get the rip to c8 and
they like to root the bishop there yeah
I like the rook on f7 should swing over
to the Queen side as well so maybe it's
not a bad move but I just like okay rook
c8 here and from the perspective again
remember Wesley has won five games in a
row everybody you know you you would say
that even though way II kind of blew the
last one and could have won at this
point if he just gets a draw and and
officially stops the bleeding you're
probably happy if your way eita to kind
of get it get a half a point with black
yeah but this is gonna be a very tough
save if it's even possible that's really
you think so
rook d2 o k f5 also looks pretty good
but I'd say rook d2 is running roopd a
check Jesus I don't understand why this
is so hard I can meet f6 with g6
oh okay rook g6 I guess I feel like
maybe this is White's got a lot of
pressure coming with these pawns but
then what it's obstacle bishops and how
am I so rook c8 check o c5 just hack the
pawns we're dudes keep it fresh on the
pawns then play King f4 uh-huh continue
an attack okay I don't know if I would
agree to a draw here okay Brooke see if
I play it yeah wait can for you mind
when g6 but yeah I want to put my bishop
on c4 though where I guard critical
squares play a four so okay well this
King is moving up King h7 Bishop c4 h5 I
want to sit tight there you go
the big issue right now is look at his
his connection right clearly he's got oh
oh I thought that might have been in
he's got two seconds now which means he
made that last one with one second
if wayy loses this one because of time
oh my gosh
wow I'm getting too old for this bleep
yeah this is I mean 1.3 seconds left no
he's gonna flag oh my gosh he made it
again it again now he's got to play a
four but this is where Wesley is shining
0.2 the lag is so lag is real the pain
is real oh my gosh there it goes oh my
gosh he's in a tough spot tough spot
with his lag and they get one more
five-minute game and was he again very
happy leans back in the chair just yeah
this is for wayy he just can't spend so
much time early on especially with his
lag I mean even disregarding the
connection for a second if he was you
know not even having this kind of
difficulties
he's just getting himself with time
trouble and came like that no I was just
about to make the same point regardless
of lag and connections because Wesley
doesn't seem to be on the most Rockstar
forbore connection either I mean it's
just it's bad bad math right you're not
playing the odds well when you're
putting yourself consistently under 10
seconds Robert when the position is
still insanely complex right so and now
with only 30 seconds left we have
officially told the players that this
will be their final game in the five
minute portion we will take a quick
break but of course roughly 6000 of you
with us now you're not going anywhere
for the rest tonight thanks for being
with us on a Sunday Robert gets lonely
but now he's got 60 100 new friends Wow
okay way to call me out you're the one
who was so excited for everyone to come
on and have people to talk to because
you know I ignore you half the time yeah
you do it's is this you know a
relationship Johnny we're just talking
about how mean you are to us sometimes
mr. Virgil you know I have my moments
yeah so getting this game we see a
catalan with a queen on c2 early which
means that white is completely ready for
pond 64 now I don't like this Queen on
c2 because it feels place become victim
to a very quick hit say yeah okay this
is not what I was no but I says this is
I've seen this before I guess
Bishop g5 I guess cuz it's a weird
position we're black if you give like
like three moves everybody in these
positions they play Bishop takes c5 they
put the pawn on e5 and you know move the
Queen bring the rook and black it's just
in like a fantastic Benoni with colors
reversed but the problem is that that
White has moves like III coming Bishop
c5 and it's usually black struggles to
kind of get all of those all of those
moves and here look at this move by c3
taking me to the pin threatening perhaps
in Knight a4 and Knight b-52 really gang
up on this D pawn yeah this definitely
looks like some sort of theory but I'm
not very well versed on it let's see do
I play Knight d5 Knight e5 is
interesting the point everybody is that
if we go to chop town at the end of
these lines there's discoveries on the
Queen combined with the fact that the
bishop is loose yeah you can't take on
d5 isn't that doesn't make g5 come in
just winning on aged seven oh yeah lol
sorry I wasn't even focusing on
superficial discoveries everybody when
there's actually a very concrete one
Bob's your uncle
so okay yeah no but that so that 95 is
interesting and the funny thing about 95
Robert is if you don't take it then
Bishop to g5 is a really strong threat
right and and and way way he agrees but
I feel like we've been here before now
we've seen a few games now where he was
in position to strike he if he gets this
one would be a huge confidence booster
heading into the faster portion yep and
he's making a move that seemed to be
maybe there was Bishop g5 instead of 95
but 95 to me look like the move and I'm
somewhat familiar like I've seen
positions like this before and but I
don't know the nuances but I'm trying to
figure things out on the fly but I've
seen moves like 95 should come quite
quickly honestly it's just one of those
moments where you can't or shouldn't
spend thirty was at 39 seconds that's a
on a single move because as we've seen
game after game he's getting himself in
time trouble and
losing in this time crunch yeah well
right now he's not down to much on time
no no this game is better I mean he's
actually done well right now with the
white pieces to put was in a difficult
spot because yeah anytime you're in
position like this no Knight 65 there's
no difference I would take only five you
take with your queen ninety five ninety
five months again your pollen age six
merely means that you gain more pieces
for the Queen that you lose but you're
still in a tough way so here Bishop d6
so now there's a couple options for for
white to look for B for expansion which
is a kind of a traditional way to play a
reverse or a Benoni structure here if
you can get before safely maybe you get
threats of b5 to undermine the knight
protection but there's no there's still
also e3 and a lot of positions to
consider and I I'm a little more biased
to e3 if I can make it happen because
what it does for my pieces right
liberation homes opens up the D file
opens up the bishop so yeah looks good I
guess III is black have some Bishop g4
coming is that a possibility as a
response but then maybe Hughes go h3 and
they just kicked my bishop away so III
definitely looks good yeah and he goes
for it I like it and and this is
something we've been kind of talking
about with the structure here since the
beginning of this game so now it's on
white - sorry I'm black to try to try to
deal with these tactics without letting
the whole Center just become completely
undermined and blown open
there's Bishop c4 to consider rook e8
okay so h3 Bishop h5 that looks Bishop
will come to g6 in the tempo and the
Queen uh C - yeah if we go for that line
h3 h4 h5 g4 okay we're gonna we're gonna
find out I I know I just keep coming
back to it cuz I'm a I'm an old dog with
very few tricks but I loved finding an
exchange stack if I could I'd love to do
it but it doesn't really work here so
I'm just gonna stop stop looking for it
yes we 2d3 the ideas if you take on d3
I'll have a four at some point right
that's a idea that might be looming from
black but if you go d3 something as a
pawn gets overextended and I can move my
queen away and they come after in a few
moves so you have to be very careful
before making them like d3 as black I
think white can play
he takes d4 here also you're gonna take
on f3 first you could even take with the
knife first though I mean oh okay that's
also fair so Eve 4 is played by white
interesting so you get the advantage of
cementing your night for the
disadvantage of forget about your
pressure on my D pawn right now that's a
forever passer if the bishop was not on
d2 I would have said let me play Bishop
takes F 3 and then d3 put my knight on
d4 yeah
would that be 22 able to kick a knight
when ever comes before that didn't look
good that would have been a very
thematic to just steal a word that you
love using the positional sacrifice to
put a pony on a dark square that's
educational for those thinking about how
a grandmaster like Robert has thinks
your tend to be a positional you're a
positional girl in a positional world
yep let's go
love that let's go Barbie UT let's go
Bobby
let's go Bobby come on Bobby let's go
party what the night on f5 let's bring
it Knight takes d5 is a current threat
for black right black another move
there's discoveries because the Knights
undefended and the Queen on c2 is a
problem with the from age 7
so that's so Knight a5 looks very
natural considering more we're just
discussing what else do you need Queen
to b3 maybe oh yeah he he goes for it
not a bad idea to be a little more
patient I guess the biggest issue we
continue to have with Wei Yi's approach
to this point as is his his time
management
picking it up they're speeding up a
little bit these pawns are weak yep and
there's no good night discovery for the
mg6 you could take on d5 still to try to
unleash your queen to hit h4 but black
just after after white just takes the
night Queen takes h4 these seven Falls
and what would be the idea of if you
take with the discovery whoa
so he goes by g6 huh so the question is
for white do you want to take on d6 you
go 966 Queen b6 Bishop b4 winning the
extreme I'm very scared it once the
Queen comes to f6 Knight takes just
who's coming before is undermine so this
makes the right call there mainly
because he just played that move so
quickly Robert yes put the rook on c1
you've got to play fast the most
critical position has not been had yet
as long as the game is still going in an
equal sense and so you need to have time
when the critical position arises part
of that is just experience and trusting
your intuition in the format whoa okay
so what's going on here so now all of a
sudden well T V white blockade these
pawns like this rook could just
magically throw itself an e-form get one
move yeah promise rook e1 I'm going for
myself there any III nice trick that's
one way that does it because ephors
Schmitt by Brooke takes d4 and that
pokes at the a pawn here I do like that
but h5 still worries me because after h5
the g4 pawns much looser H wipe maybe I
played g5 and say come get me no okay
efore is coming we're gonna see what
Wesley has in mind what's the point not
a free pawn on d4 yam wondering what's
the point looking at now Wesley's face
he must have calculated something or no
he Manik Bishop eath Bishop III he wants
the battery of the Queen and Bishop
well it doesn't diagonals it's a rook h1
rook each one is a is actually a
surprisingly just like good move right
because as passivism move like that
normally is it just defense everything
well I think you had to right you can't
want that Queen go to h2 of course yeah
now that it's there there's no attack
yep at least none that I see
rook takes eight
can you whites next yeah I've been you
want to be careful about b2 because if B
to Falls a3 probably comes with it so if
White's gonna to play for a win
I wonder if even a more patient approach
Robert like okay like even Queen e2 is a
move I want to play just to guard the c2
squared guard B - I don't know
no well I like this because if you take
on b2 and now I've Queen d7 for town and
okay it's a queen b5 keeps a fork attack
and now Queen d4 for right all night
lady trade taking the e5 square way you
can play rook d1 next we're not getting
made in your upper pond this is a great
endgame but I see the 18 point nine
seconds 11 and I see the lag fault I had
not right now but I've seen lag in
previous right now they seem to be on
about the same level of connection to
our server but if way he moves on past
this particular match with Wesley we'll
definitely encourage him maybe we'll
find it's time to play play the next one
while he's in Europe or something yep so
Bishop c3 play it quickly
there you go you're threatening rook t4
just move grandmaster move rook d8 rook
d7 is also a threat fork town on the
pawns yep so right now white is just
threatening Brooke before this is
terrible forty sevens a threat
everything's a threat so I think the
game is actually completely lost to this
point rook da check okay rewriting the
King makes me out like this centralized
rook d4 is a move i I want to play but
it's smart to be a little more p8 is
mate now just e8 yep yeah Weston must
have missed that so g a5 g a5
I simply working out you go Brooke 8005
Jia 5 f6 then Bishop takes f6 there so
he'll go rook GA check ready and then
rookie aid then discoveries and it's
over
Wow a big win there for the Grand Master
from China who not sure if the players
are aware but now they know that it's a
break a few minutes for Wesley to think
that world which he's gonna need because
that's a momentum changer right Robert
those are the kind of victories that get
you back in a match especially when
you've lost such a heartbreaker before
but you don't let it affect you
emotionally you win the next one and you
said you take it into a cut the lead to
only three games heading into the three
men
it we're gonna be right back everybody
with commentary for the three minutes
don't go anywhere over the next 90
seconds just sit there maybe get some
popcorn maybe put some pants on get some
Cheetos we'll see you soon
[Music]
and Wesley is back sitting in his chair
wayy not quite yet the the curtain he's
hiding behind the curtain but Robert
okay a big win there for wayy to send it
into a send us into the three-minute I
think we still have a match in our hands
what are your thoughts on on the
momentum of things so far well there are
nine straight decisive games to close
the five-minute portion we may get
better than that if you're a fan not at
all it's really awesome way to see I
mean wait he's been playing well Wesley
so at some points it's been so precise
really impressing me with his accurate
play he's just out maneuvered way and
some some games and others he's kept the
time pressure up and that's really been
telling the tale I think so far is that
even with always been outplayed in
certain dynamics he just can't hold what
seemed like holdable positions because
he's getting down to under 10 seconds
left and more importantly than the 10
seconds is in critical moments are not
even critical moments he's spending 30
seconds on a move that should be played
quick and it felt like almost like right
when you were talking about that where
he crossed under the minute mark and we
said you just have to move trust your
intuition and we really liked this move
work a 2c1 it almost felt like he got a
little bit of a feeling of exactly what
we're talking about right that he didn't
need to sit there and try to win the
game right then he needed to play
quickly and give himself a chance later
on right you think that's a fair thing
to say that I feels like he adjusted
there in those last couple games oh for
sure and he played a really nice game
there in the last round and the reason
why is you made that comment he the best
thing about a move someone who is he
made was that he made them quickly yeah
in that position he ended up playing you
know rook c4 which is a very nice
defensive resource and played it quickly
was the over press when efore lost the D
pawn and then from there is alway and I
think what he's doing in this game was
also very good he spent only 10 seconds
- Wesley is now 25 but more importantly
he's getting a position that's very
double-edged and playing quickly so I
think when you get a position like this
just making moves fast can often be more
important than playing the single best
move so after b3 let's see what would
you do here okay took on b3 he's
entering this line yep I'm not a big fan
of this from
the black side because I think that but
the brook staring down the a7 pond
there's such a clear counter play for
white
I wouldn't even necessarily win the pawn
back immediately by trying to go out for
the night and c6 on a7 I play moves like
Knight BD - or Bishop b2 forget to c1
Bishop d2 makes perfect sense as well it
stops 85 from being an easy option now
after 95 for white you can take on e5
back and put a shove a 5 hit the c7 pawn
so it's very good things here in in
White's position I think black it's
nothing too terribly yet but I'm just
always worried about the backward pawns
that's the real downside of playing with
like b5 this should be 7 is nice because
we like Queen takes b5 then Black has
moves like Knight takes d4 with
discoveries in the Queen so interesting
dynamic as far Wednesday a little bit
ahead in the clock which I think yeah
just about to say what's about to get a
little bit ahead but it does feel like
both players were aware of the
transition not to say that they weren't
aware but they both have have been
playing a little faster here to start
this one compared to the previous game
so yep so now for OK at White's
attacking c6 and if you move your night
away I'm going to take on b7 so for
example night before I played Bishop
takes b7 rook takes b7 Bishop takes
before Bishop takes before throw in 93
then take on a6 things like that you
know do seem to favor white here black
maybe can try does it work
I want that move like b4 and the reason
why I want to play b4 is is a theme to
go 97 to b5 I know you make fun of me
for saying somatic but playing before it
does allow this night to go a step 97 to
b5 and try to go into c3 at some moment
no I don't make fun of you I just like I
just I I'm so glad I have somebody in my
life who uses words like that just
trying to teach something every now and
then and speech speaking of thematic I
did see yasser ser one that's
grandmaster and many time us champion
yasser Sarah Wanda man himself up way
past his bedtime yeah that's true
actually I didn't think about that but
we love the as we love all the coverage
of Beale by the way if you haven't been
watching the the chest broad channel
it's been it's been pretty good stuff
watching yes or Sarah won't break down
the Beale games every day so
nearly 6,000 of you with us thanks for
being here reminder that any any
donations cheers bits or otherwise all
go directly to the players we see we've
increased the prize fund by about forty
four big ones throughout this match
that's enough for Wesley to to go get
himself a at Jimmy John's sandwich so
that's cool
you don't have Jimmy John's in New York
though for you Robert no Jimmy John's is
not a popular New York thing and wait
what just happened did we blunder upon
smile
oh if eight takes be five Bishop c6
Bishop c6 Knight d5 and that's not gonna
be fun
four-way takes you six you might just
bite the bullet play queen c8 because
you really don't want a lot that night
to jump in the c6 course so quickly okay
this is he's going for it which means
like you said problems really bad so
Brooke b6 Knight take c7 Queen d7 I
really don't like the Brooke a7 you just
been Bishop a5 to follow I think you're
just losing the C pawn yeah a lot of
things falling here this is really
really not looking good
let's see some work a second so what can
like even do here the good news is the
light squares are a bit weak so my queen
can go let's say Queen d7 d okay well
the 98th it doesn't matter I was gonna
say Queen d7 to d5 took 194 things like
nice move there one of the funny things
about the bishop coming to b4 is it
doesn't even matter if you moved your
queen there's still gonna be a lot of
problems with the Brooke on their fate
and the pawn of c7 so okay
96 each is gonna give up the c7 pawn but
not sure where the compensation is
coming from yeah we take c7 take with a
seer oke just now you have to Brooks in
the seventh rank your upper pawn bishop
before Bishop a maybe Bishop a5 first
and then Bishop before but this is just
a very nice accurate play by Wesley so
once again you get a good position he
doesn't you know make it is let's point
back into the game at all okay Bishop
before now he starting Bishop to c5 the
f7 pawn is weak and resignation wow that
was like that almost happened too fast
you know like one way you'd remember
this matches you mean like it all
happened so fast
are you trying to sing summer lovin had
me left you know what I had me a blast
say that much we've got confirmation
that Jimmy John's is alive and well in
Jersey
so if Roberts looking to take that drive
to the to the Garden State yeah not very
often
alright I was in Madison New Jersey last
month though so I I saw friends play but
speaking of play we see another catalan
being played and this time was he was in
the black side and Bishop c6 these lines
the point is by putting your Bishop on
c6 you can actually continue him to
bother this Queen on c4 so I can play
Bishop b5 and this is just blade and if
the Queen goes the d3 r2 c2 you can play
Bishop b4 it's always a move you get
thrown if you'd like right and he and he
does like
but one of the funny things about this
maneuver though is white ultimately
wants the bishop to land on e4 before
going to c1 it's just a slightly more
loose square allows you to develop your
own night with tempo whether that be a
c3 or d2 so as far as a thematic type of
common retreat there by white this Queen
c2 allowing the tempo is not by accident
to try to get this type of position and
then for exactly the reasons you're
seeing here
and here black will play c6 but Knight
1/6 of e4 and say my my pawn structure
is impenetrable you can play e4 and try
to make it even larger setup it doesn't
matter because if you ever try to break
through with me big d 5 also trading
everything if you play E 4 E 5 from
White's perspective now where you're
gonna make progress from so here blacks
next move pretty much no matter what
would be c6 maybe if it's like Queen c2
them I play knight c6 first is to go to
b4 but c6 yeah for sure is gonna be
played right now
I like rook d1 though because even with
what you highlight it was c6 9 8 6 night
before it takes a few moves so you
wonder if Y can play e4 and on a move
like Knight a 6 look to do something
aggressive in the center while you can
okay no he plays h4 interesting he's
maybe played preparing an idea like 95
Knight g4 kind of a a bluff at a King
side attack some sort of pressure over
there not not exactly sure I mean I
might go for 95 here anyway if I'm wayy
because I don't think the trade on e5
really favors black to give white the D
file too quickly so 95 within a 6 it's
actually 95 is certainly a good looking
option because when you play 95 and if
black takes and take with the pawn you
put a rook on d6 you throw another
Brooke to d1 your queen that for things
like that so we know for I think is a
good starting point and Queen c7 was
played ok if we trade Queens it's gonna
be very difficult for you to break
through so he keeps the ladies on the
board yeah but but what's next that's
the problem I think you put III for
example and you might have to write but
then black is choosing between do I keep
it sold or I even look to maybe play c5
and open up my own Bishop on f6
yes rook see one stop see five but Queen
b6 now the Queen's on g4 and there's no
real attack on this side of the board so
Queen b6 puts pressure on those pawns
and Queen from b6 and go it to be four
to check a four so I really like the
move Queen b6 theory instead he put
night before which makes sense because
matter before is strong it stops d5 from
ever happening
the knight is in a good position to hop
into more aggressive places if need be
Queen goes back to you four and it makes
me wonder again what was the point of
this whole shuffle right this is this
isn't shuffle puck you know yeah it's
not the Bears Super Bowl winning team
that's right or a Mighty Ducks reference
that went over your head I actually got
it I just didn't want to know I'm
kidding I'm kidding nothing goes over
your head we showed you our slip starts
lipstick oh I can't tongue-twister I was
gonna say hard to say that five times
fast you say what else you might want to
try to say five times fast Wesley so is
an anagram for slow eyes look at his
eyes slowly creeping up the board if
anyone ever wonders what exactly do we
keep my client on staff for at chess
calm it's it's for a stat boy coming up
with things like that there you go
that's what he's doing with this time so
okay tell me what it should take these
things you've got a guy that sack g4
look at me we talked about bluffing at a
King side attack and why is bluffing
anymore that's what I'm saying I was you
know we joked that it was bluffing
earlier when we didn't understand the
Queen shuffles but now now King G to
prepare to play the move h5 maybe he's
thinking about h5 now which is why he
hasn't moved yet I would have quickly
just played King g2 and rook h1 and I
think that again he took like 10 seconds
on that move and I know we've been
beating on this drum here but you just
you have to you have to not try to
calculate whether h5 is the most
accurate move yet you have to let the
pieces sort of play themselves and and
give yourself more time when it's really
gonna matter here and a few more moves
so I am that would be my criticism of
the last few moves not that he's not
getting an attack but he's getting under
20 seconds in the process so Bishop e7
the threat is F
just for the rule in fact we just
created that trap right but that's an
interesting sacrifice because by f5
queen takes six and six also we take
chief for late night e5 hitting g6 yeah
you can play move like rook g1 h5 also
yes five stops it now everyone f5 has
just met straight up by this we have an
f5 Queenie six F takes G for Queen takes
g6 check King f8 I'm not sure who's you
know if White's delivery checkmate or
just down a piece for two pawns but
that's the way you have to play in a
blitz match yeah so if you take on h5 I
simply take back or I probably throw in
95 one of those aggressive moves oh very
nice Queen d6 points out the point of
rook age three being bad we talked about
a couple seconds ago the bishop is
trapped so yeah I think you could have
thrown in h6 check perhaps we're taking
on f5 right away and got in the third
pawn so yeah this is just this should
just be losing yeah right
he only has one pawn for the piece and
he's back to back to his old enemy
living off the increment with only 2.1
seconds should just be losing huggin
Knight c4 and trying to take on a 5 ok
yeah you probably should've done that
not even because whether it was gonna be
enough to win that pawn but any trade
you can avoid when you're down a piece
and I see 4 would have been better so 93
stopped at five to the e5 home is
hanging yep a little bit of technique
shilling there by Wesley rook takes B -
I mean b7 is protected so it's not like
ya protected multiple times in fact now
this is this is always a right now yep
I like what was he did there he took a
little while to make them move probably
trying to flag his opponent he's
completely winning right so whether he
wins on the border on time you still get
the same full point but I like to
spending a little bit of time and there
we see yeah wait whose eyes wins by
resignation away ye resigning and now
down by five games he's uh as his
position is changing slightly clearly a
little frustrated with himself but I
think overall the games have been very
very close but the consistent the
consistent thing that's repeating is
that Wesley's got more time when it
really matters and Wesley is very
creative defensively yeah that of5 queen
d6 I saw f5 coming that I was you know I
saw a queen on e4 bish one g4 that
couldn't yell ooh I'm singing at five
but I wasn't quite saying was well if I
sacrifice on e6 how do I safeguard my
king and queen d6 with a really nice way
of doing so because you could have taken
on g4 and it got crazy and that's all
the craziness that was he wanted he said
you know maybe you'll get three pawns
from the piece but I'll be able to
manage that so Wesley so his
resourcefulness is very obvious and
impressive reminder to all 6,000 plus of
you what you're watching it's the 2018
speech Chess Championship thank you to
all of our subscribers all those who
donated we see all of you not not not
giving everyone a shout out really
focusing on the chest during these big
events but we really do appreciate all
the support I see abacus Finch one of my
favorite diamond members and subscribers
and the chest TV and twitch chat just
want to let everyone to know we love you
we're following you and if you want to
follow the whole event as we see this
next game going make sure you tweet or
follow the hashtag speech s on Twitter
see what everybody's talking about
throughout the next several months as we
get closer to crowning our next speed
chess champion and there we go we see
this next game rolling on there to the
left but go ahead go ahead and search
the hashtag speed chess and get involved
I'm not gonna search the hashtag but I
don't you why aren't you huh I'm gonna
talk about hashtag chess right here you
will go to sleep all right we'll put you
to sleep you're in my world now Bobby
yes no way he is early e5 in fact
typically you don't play u5 so quickly
you wait for you make them with a back
on move 10 you make a look
he broke through with E 5 very quickly
but at least according to topical lines
it gives white an advantage because you
can play have 4 and this is exactly what
just happened and for black and you
don't take on c3 well then White has
tremendous space yep you do take on c3
and play I don't even know it I played
Bishop e6 to try to get c4 so white you
respond fishing III here after the check
straight bishops yeah I'll just trade
off those bishops say I have a huge
spatial advantage
ok the c-4 square is not that big a deal
so maybe wasn't thinking what happens to
king h1 but then Bishop e6 seems like a
tempo gaining more yeah it's straight
forward here for white and again it
feels like Wesley is we predicted these
guys would not be afraid to play their
favorite openings and really try four
edges none of this none of this bull at
b3 g3 Hikaru stuff right these guys are
playing mainline openings but it feels
like the last several games Wesley has
gotten better positions out of the
opening even more than he was to start
so what's going on here yeah this trade
on d4 now I know white is a perfect time
here and you see the power of the
centralized pawns well it Queen up to I
guess you take what the King on f2 you
did with a rook and try to take over the
D file but somehow I'm not a big fan of
the Queen trade okay I don't like this
way to creat trade for black either cuz
what a Queen because now my D files
gonna fall for White Queen takes d4 rook
d4 Knight b5 just seems annoying for
black because when we look back to d7 I
think then I go a 5 and so if you go c6
I have the d6 score so I don't like what
either side that did there I didn't like
the trade on f2 the thought black should
take there and yes why it's slightly
better but I think you have more of an
advantage with the Queens on the board
because the Queen on d4 actually was a
quick target you play rook do you own
with tempo you play yeah 5 by 94 would
go over the f6 square the King is unsafe
on the Kings side now for black play
Roxy form is rook d7 looks bad really
passive so rook c4 and I guess the point
is the deep
isn't anything you played review when I
was a bishop in chief for but I'm
thinking maybe just rook AC one and yeah
okay see one look to me to move like see
if you attack the knight I'll come into
one of these squares maybe even d6 and
kind of reinforce the outpost eventually
with you five okay rook FC one but III
agree with everything you just said and
your analysis was amazing and I think
it's instructive to highlight for the
fans that the main reason Robert didn't
like queen of two is because if you keep
the Queen's on the board that's your
best chance at using your space
advantage for white and the attack so
strange by Wesley and then strange by
way ye and I still feels like White's
got an edge but I agree that the chances
of using the space advantage you gained
have gone really gone away for white and
the danger for white right Robert is
that if you if you get nothing at all
then blacks three-on-two actually
becomes the better pawn majority than
whites four on three right yep so you
took on c1 which I don't know how I feel
about that but did you really have a
choice I thought before potentially that
way to meet but to me this is getting
close to the position that I'm thinking
Wiggy if you're black is okay play a
four now you're gonna play Bishop e6 if
you can get Knight d7 and try to use
your three on two and it just feels like
we're headed more and more to a position
where yes okay white is objectively
still better here that I don't d6 is
very strong you should play e5 but I
just don't see a lot of I don't feel
like white got as much as he could have
from that middle game I like Bishop e6
now 97 so I can get b5 can I do this yep
maybe King f8 King e7 instead okay I
mean yeah I don't like the pawn to a4
that's the one thing that's keeping me
from feeling like black is fully
equalized yeah so okay it takes on c8
now Brooke a5 Brooke a5 I'd have to play
Bishop b3 likely I don't really want to
play b5 just yet right
yeah I'm trigger work a5 to a 7 but
maybe you do go Bishop b3 b5 and then
you're okay because your cousin c8 I
like this move b6 he's gonna get b6
he'll play c5 get Bishop to b3 kind of
slowly working his way out I'm liking we
use defense more and more not liking his
clock situation though
right so Bishop b5 but I guess the issue
is once these rooks get traded there's
no way to get to the a pawn because your
King has nowhere to run to what I would
try to do as white is take it with undie
tree bring my king to c3 and then try to
you just figure out the exact precise
way of doing this but really baby try
bishops it should be three king de now
mm-hmm so what happens if Bishop c4
looks like a threat so now Bishop c4 you
a bishop d1 you have to avoid the
bishops trade there yeah this is
actually a very instructive endgame yeah
it is I'm a big fan of this endgame
because it goes to show if you trade
bishops you may think oh six pounds in
six pawns but no the King is so much
faster than the action and it's gonna
burst King is is quickly getting access
to to the pawns so very easy technique
right now well I think I think way he's
fine but I think that Wesley is creating
constant threats of transitioning and in
the king of pawn ending as we said with
the bishop trade now he's he's kind of
poking at these pawns and bringing them
forward so they're all on light squares
which okay in a time scramble that could
matter eventually actually and it seems
like it matters a lot yeah because these
pawns have been and again that's very
like as we said the nagging the nagging
style of every chess mom slash Wesley so
they sort of just poking and prodding he
really induced black to push these pawns
against his will and then tighten even
if best play is still a draw this is
gonna be super hard to defend when White
has so many targets its winning now yeah
it looks like it is winning now Bishop
to g7 I was gonna say play Bishop g8
first and then II six but okay and you
did yeah I think whatever for kicks and
giggles shows seven was probably winning
as well yeah because now you can case
you can see five you can also take care
and it's just yeah this is principle of
two weaknesses too if you want to back
up this video and see an instructive
endgame look at how Wesley so just kind
of poked at the board induced weaknesses
on light squares for the bishop and
eventually black just couldn't hold yep
so this is all going right for was he so
despite sacrificing the lead early in
the match I mean yeah about two games he
hasn't lost since I know he has he has
lost one since yes but you wouldn't
expect that he was ever down in this
match considering the score yeah
nine and a half to three and a half and
I am very curious to ask way after the
match just you know was he what kind of
what it feels like to place home like
was he so game after of course he has
over the board experience it's all the
best players in the world and you see
yasser sarah one of the chats a very
impressive play by wesley big applause I
totally agree just a very accurate and
game technique there yep yep yep yep
and well now we see it another sort of
London type system going on so what is
way you can do in the white side of this
is he looks like Queen f3 and then go to
Queen h3 I think he might do that here
okay it wasn't like to have three and
you know going for the casual setup at
least he's playing very quickly he's
actually up 20 plus seconds right now
yeah and that might be the first time
we've seen this where he's gotten a head
on the clock so early he can just play
very simple moves he had Castle here go
Bishop c2 but Queen B one died at the I
like h4 though yeah go baby he's trying
to fight aggressive chess it's really
not easy to play these positions it
really isn't I I get so afraid of
playing these types of positions as
black I I avoid pushing my pawn to d5
and relinquishing the e5 square against
any London I face yep and so after age
for another think by wuzzy so finally we
see yeah this is this may be a well that
that way II comes back to you dipping
into this water because if he can get
positions like this I mean easier to
play quickly intuitively I like okay so
94 is a very important defensive shot
for everyone if you're playing black in
these positions not just because it
blocks the bishop but also prepares
moves like f6 at some point to kick the
night from e5 and start to defend but
okay so now what are whites options here
they're you're already thinking there's
gonna be lines where you could just make
a whole bunch of trades if you can
foresee a positional edge at the end of
it
meaning if you could somehow take and
double the pawns and two and trade on c6
and on d6 you might be okay but you have
to watch out for moves like Knight takes
c6 constantly being met like my bishop
takes up for inner mizo and okay so he
plays Queen c2 instead to kind of build
up I like it
so something looks weird yeah anytime I
see a bishop on d6 and Queen on c7 so
such that Knight takes c6 isn't that's
right I didn't like the move order here
I thought blacks should take it on d4
first uh-huh and the reason why is if
after C takes D for you when C takes d4
I could have thrown a check on the
diagonal if you put a takes d4 and now
f6 we've been much more powerful this
here it takes up four you take on c6 it
gives so e takes it for I think if stick
with the Queen on c6 yes you can
purchase one for sure I take any pour
right so I think that way Yi is better
here now now you can take out c5 maybe
oh that's really nice because you can't
take with a knight yeah h7 falls exactly
and you can't take with the Queen cuz
this things and some of the positions
that white is aiming for everybody it
may just be like good night versus bad
Bishop type of stuff if if y can could
control the darks worse
yep so I yeah I like the way that he's
transitioned this and again the time has
been a breath of fresh air if you're in
waves camp he's not actually probably
not gonna be the first one who crosses
under a minute here
he shouldn't be no with this great
position that he has and the fact he's
up a pawn so what you know how does
black even continue because if you put
Bishop d7 I can simply just continue
with castle or rook to d1 or something
like that yeah on c5 is still not
possible to be captured Oh f5 go b4
immediately
this is play b4 then eliminate this
Knight put a pony on e5 and go to sleep
yep yeah that was this is so far very
very nice now even you can even play g3
here I guess the point is b6 is coming
okay yeah okay 95 yep this is like
blacks worst nightmare we yeah this is a
an outpost dark square yes just castle
yep and we foreshadowed it because it's
a common transition for white in these
London turned into kind of a stone wall
structure everybody - for white to kind
of see the big picture and look for
these types of opportunities to get good
night versus bad bishop you can even
play king of two here in sac the
exchange you would do that I would add
which would be unnecesarry you're right
but it could be it could be sassy you
know okay you can also just play rook h3
that I think the main issue I have with
my king of to move is after trade if one
blacks gonna play b6 and I don't like
the position becoming open right so yeah
so I would play rook aged three and nine
aged 5 min Queen D from g1 you know what
he wants he wants king of to a tempo and
then g4g for the pain is real so g3 here
is a must I feel like is it well if he's
like Queen d2 I'll definitely go b6 I
know but I've watched you for I want it
all but G for an open guy like I like it
mean way ye we're connected right now g
4g g 4g for your first terrible I take
[Laughter]
lol's I don't know excited you are about
because I love it I love it anyway
though of course as I say this remember
the moment your moves start aligning
with Dani reg predictions it's generally
not the positive trending for white
losing for white knight takes f4 no
takes of for undermines e5 wayy why
would you go for g4
well now it's actually okay Bishop C -
yeah and did Wesley just no actually
bishop to see the still night except for
is a queen each three I guess the only
way now tonight takes a 44 is coming he
doesn't see it both of them are missing
94 yeah 4 is just now you cannot miss it
this is it it's so funny with your
mutual blindness by two players yeah
neither of them see the same blunder he
still doesn't play the right move this
is awesome it's hilarious 90 x f4 was
resides on the spot
so how still play tonight afford now he
found it's so funny I mean chess chess
like the the vibes that people get on
when their brains are calculating a
mutual blindness is a real thing in
chess games we're just neither player
sees the same idea yep
and so what's it it's the white is down
upon just down upon and King is in the
center yeah this is terrible
yeah trade and the Queen a four-minute
resigns if he resigns now oh he lost
some time oh he didn't lose on time what
no he made a move with one second again
keeps looking like he's losing time but
you know but he's making moves with with
point seconds on the clock which is my
one of my favorite things to do and
Wesley wins again so Wow a an impressive
turnaround there even if there was this
fun Mutual blunder of night takes a four
not seen by either player yeah I mean g4
was just Danny I know you were clamoring
for that move yeah it's your fault the
way you lost that hey I'll take I'll
take that one it's on me I'll put it on
the shoulders little brush it off but
you're right no it's uh in fact I see
what was I even thinking with g4 there
was no reason to do it g4 to X clams I
see a comment from Yasir g4 gasp
horrible he's like Danny have I taught
you nothing I'm gonna make it I'm gonna
make a g4 emote just from my channel
just so we remembered this moment
forever yes that was no but you're right
white played really well positionally
the bind was on the dark squares and
there was no reason to be aggressive for
the King side attack and backfire but I
think I think way you was feeling the
pressure on the clock Robert and felt
like he needed to do something and again
that's just the that's the way this
match has gone kind of you're fighting
against your own ghost when you've lost
games because of time now you're playing
faster in a position and maybe miss
playing it because you feel you have to
be too aggressive so playing against
your own ghost is bad man feels bad not
good at all reminds you of every sort of
crime fiction book I've read where the
bad guys named ghost
that of things yeah sounds like Dan
Brown unnecessary it's definitely not
Dan Brown James Patterson I love James
Patterson actually might be a dude it
probably is a James Patterson's like a
Black Friday or I've read me I've read
me some Patterson yeah good for you now
can you stop no good for you me just
well you suggesting better books than I
have what you suggested me was like G
for so I was all right well this is a
grünfeld for those who have kept track
of the chests so far we stared down
stare down Roberts book list I know what
Robert has his favorite book is you hold
you holy holy Elf Holly elf I see you
they want Dan shout out Danny say my
name I see you
JD Bryant International Master in the
chest TV sash says he feels like way he
is gonna win this game
so we'll see see if he's right block is
doing quite well in this position so
what happened to usually white goes
Bishop c7 I've seen I think maybe Eric
Obion play against Jeffrey John with
certain games like this and usually what
places Bishop on c7 and has control over
the C file so what what happened here
somehow this did not go right for white
because you don't want to take on c1
with the king and cede control over the
C file so everything going well for way
you hear yep so there's go Bishop e6
back yeah usually this isn't a bad thing
everyone when you can induce this pawn
to push without immediate follow-ups
usually the white wants to be creating a
5 or d5 and because the moment this
happens the moment there are vulnerable
targets in the center like the D pawn
things like either the night or the rook
coming to c4 so so inducing efore and
then going here is again not an accident
although okay Brooke C one is slightly
irritating I guess b5 holds things down
just fine yeah and there's also nothing
is really under attack right so I can
even play me like king of fade and just
hold my knight my knight on a five to
protect c4 but yeah b5 yeah well it gets
sense the thing is what's good about b5
here is well you've the two-on-one
majority and outside the
bored but you're also not as worried
about your palm becoming weakness as in
the Catalan say here rook d8 seems to
make sense because you're gonna
something's happening on the sea for
square so you might as well go after the
d4 square so I think Brooke d8 is okay
remain rip Diego d5 rook rook da you
said d5 yeah yeah so he takes it instead
f6 now he's gonna try to improve the
position of the king king f7 perhaps
it's gonna hope that his Knight is
better than that bishop but the bishop
looks really good right now yeah king of
sevens good movies good recommendation
so now maybe this is how the Grunfeld
does well when it does well right just
the center has gone nowhere for white
black has the long term advantage of the
two versus one pawns over here everybody
and hopes to create a passer that means
something so now even rook a six yeah
this feels good feels good for Wei Yi it
does JD JD Bryant calling it John Daniel
Bryan well I guess your are trying to
take on d3 so maybe I so I don't like
whoopsie - I thought no I hate to is
hang yes I know I thought maybe I go
rookie one day anticipated Bishop trade
but neither side is trading on d3 quite
yet I think black is better here though
because Bishop takes d3 if I when I see
force extremely annoying right you know
so you des you and rook be - his idea is
to stop this would be three with the
pond b5 hanging Gary Brooks c6 Meeks
like yeah nice patient approach you can
play a six even if you need to deal with
tactics here other than time this is the
kind of game that it's way ease way you
used to get
so Crazy's probably gonna just play a
six now you might be looking to
infiltrate quickly on the C file flip
over to the G file you know okay I like
Brooks c1 no okay
why oh you know what was interesting is
maybe there was a threat that you
couldn't play Brooke c2 because 95 check
went to a winning king upon ending yeah
so this is actually really bad for white
now yeah night III is it a five begin
the point of 98 3 is to stop the rook on
the C file try to go B for myself it's
now playing 1983 followed by b4 yeah I
like it
93 also stops the move Bishop c1 by the
way okay he goes for the rook inning
which is also not as bad okay I don't
know that that really helps his winning
chances anymore though I do like your 93
better but I was thinking if you can
take with the pawn you've made these
pawns sort of stuck in backward this
isn't it that easy for white to defend
this rook ending right so I wonder it if
you trade on c2 I guess that's gonna be
bad from for white but I'm just
wondering at one moment you know you can
potentially trade so exactly King c5
welcomes RUP c2 with King b6 if you
trade on c6 you're gonna problem this
endgame I feel like yeah white should be
losing just based on the two-on-one and
blacks King will get to c5
oh okay well Wesley's gonna put that to
the test King upon ending time here we
go
get your notebooks out now Kingston
final go f4 wait yeah I think I have
four right just a creative pass pawn but
you don't leave it leave it and play b4
I was gonna say play b4 let him take
take ok never but you have to be careful
because you don't want to be stuck in
sook long but you're not that worried
about the pawns all you really want is
the ability to to eventually win on the
King side here which is what he's trying
to do h6 and g5 is probably met by f5
though that's the problem
oh wow so here we go this is this is
what I was saying is this is not exactly
a threat to take because now you go back
to f7 and East 6th and
yeah I can't go to H say some King age
six is just to lose so probably this
games getting in a draw so what yeah
like you said well black one it was f
takes e5 yeah thank you
Dixon so was he offered to draw yeah I
think I think that was the the the best
that black could get there in the king
of which is disappointing for where you
cuz it makes you realize 95 was was
definitely not as good as you're playing
with 93 so yeah I just was trying not to
trade pieces when I feel like I have an
initiative going and I'm trying to take
over an open file I just wanna play 93
d4 and go for work C to me check but
credit so Wesley so who found that that
was a drawing like instantly yeah and
even we were like oh we look trades that
might be bad he's like nope I'm gonna
trade those off right away and I'm gonna
make a jar with no problem so that ends
the 13 decisive games in a row and we
had seen to that point there you go
we're back to the theory that we've seen
but before remember this was Wesley so
playing the white side wow this is
actually kind of funny that there yeah
they flip colors we if you just joining
us there was a pretty interesting game
in the five minute portion where we had
the black side of this exact same line
now the move is a 5-4 black and the
point is that Knight takes c6 is not
threatening to win a piece
okay 95 also move the defense the bishop
but the point is that this move is met
by this and blacks okay this is all
theory actually seven
I forget who won that game was that were
the ones the way you won is black was
that one of the day it takes a for chat
that's right that's right yeah way you
won this same line as black so now he's
taking the opposite color and we have a
theoretical battle on our hands
yeah wait so see no that doesn't work I
forget that you're down a piece is black
so I'm like oh I'm trying to go see
three and just play as if nothing's
happened but I probably should try to
get my piece back so they just that pawn
takes c6 you'll take on c4 that looks
kind of weird you could is this how it's
Nakamura beat Gary I think he went like
I don't think 95 is as good as a 5
because of this line I actually think
that way II knew the theory may be
slightly better than Wesley because way
you played a 5 not 95 right now Wesley
is in a position where he's forced to go
to the double pawn type of ending and
white in fact here I think way he
probably keeps the bishop first maybe
played Bishop g3 first okay it's
possible you can also just take and and
I guess you're immediately bringing it
but now of course black hand take on a
forward check but they're gonna for I
take back your problem before on c6 and
trying to claim a kind of advantage in
the endgame but it's good for white out
of the way so so far it feels like way
he's gotten the better of this line as
far as proving who who who knows it
deeper rook takes c6 seems pretty clear
you could play king of three maybe yeah
so rook takes c6 Knight takes F for
check ETA except for Bishop d6 b3 I
don't wanna lose that B pawn bishop
takes f4 so now you equalize the
material then King f3 and after King f3
I can go rook a 6 next and that White's
just better there yeah it's it's a 2
result kind of position why does white
is pushing forever again right the
problem is that he's also pushing the
limit on how much time pressure you can
get in and expect to win I mean why did
it take so long for him to find that
move in her line that he knows well
makes you wonder
yep and he's just playing with a better
position with the white pieces and as
we've you know keep noting yasss erawan
he's in the chat
he must be loving White's position here
g3 now and just played g3 put that
Bungie to okay King III also good
threatening to c6 bond now rook b6 just
g3 still now g3 again I mean I don't
know how many times I'm going to say
them with g3 in a row i same idea
Fischer comes to e4 but I like g3 better
because it protected the f4 pawn and
here just work hc1 continue the pressure
this is grateful whether it's winning is
another story but this is very very nice
for white yep
so here's what Wesley wanted to get when
he played it his white but failed to do
so
so Bishop b4 Brooke b6 can I do the
Fisher and take on h7 that's Mike wanna
do the Fischer I guess you couldn't but
I wanted to its rook a for who c5 I like
that yeah that's the right approach here
I think sacrifice the a7 pollen just to
get rid of your weaknesses best chance
of defending me again oh ho look at that
move no thank you
not undone your C pawns yeah that's a
very good move because if you took on c5
of course the bishop would take and then
blacks happy you took on a 7 you would
have problems with your pawn takes d4
check well by 2 B 4 so d5 is a good move
to try to keep the advantage going oh I
used to pick on d5 okay so we're still
gonna try to force it even at the risk
of the f7 pawn takes what's he saying
about rook takes up for work at 4 he's
saying well here just King f3 but he's
what he's saying is that you have CC
pawns I have as a pawn an outside passed
on so I can go King f3 now King me - I
don't know the specific matter in that
position well maybe it does rook t4 is
annoying come 92 but it's still just
kind of a check at this point
but King f3 Bishop takes h2 now that's
why we did g1 yes man you just fissure
the bleep out of me I think I get away
with that but then maybe Oh at their
fishery we're gonna find out maybe he
should've played King f1 to stop Bishop
takes h2 because then g3 worked I think
so I think Bishop c4 here Bishop g1 you
meet with Bishop e2 okay and Bishop c4
your ideas go a4 a5 a6 and then move
your rook away so actually white is
still clearly better here
yeah although actually Bishop e5 might
come d4 ah this should be five coming to
be forward hits a5 no coming to d4 but
even Bishop d4 is still met by Bishop e2
yeah and he goes for it anyway but do I
have g5g for check I guess so he's
trying for this exact setup he's trying
to put a bishop on d4 and play g5 g for
chai you have King III here okay he
doesn't go for one I wonder what King
III would temple in the rook but now
Bishop before fall but g5 is huge so
Bishop g4 yeah now there's no King III I
I think that that was huge and if he
loses this game under time pressure oh
that's huge loss giving up the a pawn is
just conceding - he's probably he's
probably gonna lose now I mean frankly
just looking at time and looking at the
situation g5 and g4 comes anyway because
you win the bishop oh my gosh
everything's going we're home
everything's going wrong right now
Bishop c4 okay just run
kingi for taken war hope you have a draw
what's they will give check on it for I
bet ya instead of taking King D 3 any
one time Oh barely that was the right
move by Wesley though - tried to get him
to lose on time
0.3 you have to pre move there
you know Quinton quick mouse skills for
Wei Yi and it's just I said that was he
wins on time way he's just uh just
unable to to avoid the time pressure his
connection is actually better than it
even was to start the match but he's
just
losing these games under but again you
know we we the the stronger player is is
winning regardless of how they win right
whether it's on time or all the board
and I think that it doesn't mean that
the criticism isn't fair that the time
should be managed differently it's just
that Wesley gets a ton of a ton of
credit for being creative like you said
putting pressure defending resourcefully
when he needs to and just creating
problems for his opponent to solve like
this little mini Bishop takes 82 bishops
you one problem right he went fissure
never go never go full fissure yes the
half fissure seems the way to have
fissure no it's very impressive he just
has great technique and all right so now
we see it and was it with the white side
of this position he's up upon so like us
to prove compensation in the Blitz game
I always think taking the gambit
yeah in a big it's this is not the
gambit where all of a sudden blacks have
to checkmate you it's a gambit where
okay maybe black will get enough
conversation to equalize and that's
great at the high Grandmaster level in
classical chess but in blitz it's so
difficult and so I think that this is a
very good choice by Wesley something
that you'd likely would not play in a
classical game because as I mentioned
with computer analysis you're backing
I'm Thor the black as great play here
but right now not looking so hot yeah no
you're right and we have questions being
asked whether this is book it is book
but again it may not necessarily be the
best book to choose in this format so
yes there's some questions in the twitch
chat and I sat out too Maynard monkey
who answered it you you do get time back
for lag it's the I honestly don't know
all the details of how how it works but
there is latency forgiveness to some
degree and then that you know it's
calculated based on when when when we're
able to detect when the move actually
reaches someone which browser versus
when it reached the server and that's
sort of try to keep the games as fair as
possible even to people with bad
connections that way but it's hard it's
hard and overall it's just not exactly
why this happening but he's getting
himself under time pressure which is
just like we said not not consistently a
good idea
though here what happened it for b3 he's
got to be be through these take over the
C file now yeah rook could bring the
rook over to c8
you could also take on f3 here by the
way you could have taken on f3 first
because the Queen was sort of overloaded
and doubled the pawns and had five shots
yeah but you can still do it he's no
Queen b5 Dani so you can't cancel Oh
sneaky Robert well that is the huge
downside of taking on the c7 is that you
just give up the C file and you are down
quite a bit of time and development so
Queen B 5 is coming stopping you from
castling here Queen B 5 I don't care how
many pawns I potentially give up Wendy 5
is the move and actually I'm gonna go
Bishop f8 next after Queen d5 I couldn't
be 5 I think he fired first
you choose a nice quick move though by
Wesley when you just recognize you're in
a tough spot you know he's just gonna
try to play the most intuitive way to
simplify out the position make sure he
doesn't get made it and I think black
has compensation but I just think the
quickness of which he responds it just
really sets the tone that now way he's
gonna try to prove something and look at
the time tick away yep
so you 5 go e5 you got it you can take a
three first if you want and then go a 5
I agree with that soon take f3 takes e5
makes sense you're opening the position
you're targeting the d4 pawn yep
do it do it and before you take 30
seconds on it this should be for is
probably what he's looking at by the way
because it threatens rooks e2 and Queen
d3 actually before it looks just very
good I was looking at that as another
option but ok he has 91 if he won
actually probably works d1 rook c1 queen
d3 King e1 oh I see you already was save
K so he eventually goes for this but
again problem is that it took took
exactly 59 seconds for him to decide on
Bishop takes up 3 in a through minute
game that's a lot and II takes d4 now is
bad because you've Chuck a queen a5
that's a nice move yeah between c3 is
met by takes here if the king
moves now you're looking at ways to take
on d4 so can I take on a to take on a to
Queen c8 issue my fave Bishop e5 Queen B
threes check we're gonna find out
Queen C eights gonna be played I'm
guessing Bishop f8 yeah I like the fact
that if you try to take the e pawn I'll
get the outside pass pawn with the a
pawn so I would go yeah Queens xb7 here
probably but so we're gonna get this
line the line that I'm showing on the
analysis board is what's gonna happen
indeed it does now you have to deal with
Bishop d6 everybody if you're if you're
black that's that's a problem so he
brings the clean back with check you'll
probably put the lady on d5 you can put
on b4 as well that's true maybe before
is just a easy if he's playing tickle
gain in some increment clock now Queen
before okay Queen before checkmate he's
gonna repeat too many times it's gonna
be a draw well maybe he was actually in
danger of losing if you don't Queen B
before because that Bishop is very
strong there waiking Oh d5 d6 very
quickly as well so okay lots of
calculate got it all right well he
settles on the draw so after nothing but
decisive chess we've had a couple of
peaceful results yeah and so who we see
now was he's taking the black pieces and
okay
d4 Dan I have six very early in this one
but why is we spending time I moved to
I'm not sure
down by 8 games which is likely likely
gonna be really tough to overcome and
bullet we still don't know exactly what
wiggies bullet prowess is you mentioned
that he's been playing a lot of bullet
on chest comm to prepare for this but
tough spot to be in
with with that much of a deficit to
overcome yep so was the dodging you know
dodging top positions in several
different games he's getting good
positions as well so it's not like he's
just in a bad position every single game
the difference is he's converting his
advantage
yep and we might not wait absolutely is
not okay g4 is a sort of desperation
attack in my opinion I'm not saying it's
bad I think objectively it's perfectly
fine but I think it's one of those
showing me that I just need to get a win
and I don't care how I'm gonna throw my
pieces at you I don't necessarily
disagree with the strategy though and
all of Roberts students out there can
ear muff it for me
earmuffs if you're Roberts student you
can earmuff it but you know from a
practical perspective even though you
always want to be as objective as
possible you have to create a chance to
win if you don't bring this match within
a couple of games before bullet you have
no chance mathematically you almost have
no chance so so I'm with it I'm with the
aggressive play I'm with it as well oh
you are damned you didn't tell you you
can say hey buddy your mother for me you
know I don't want your money buddy
because you know you are right there was
an eight game deficit you had going to
the bullet portion yep Wesley so it was
a good bullet player you know he may not
be hit karo Nakamura love a bullet
player but he's good and so in order to
get +8 in the remaining time you need to
win these last two or three-minute games
or at least within six games but I think
it's realistically Wednesday's gonna be
hard to knock off here because you're up
12 and at four and a half and the way
the games have been going and I don't
really have not seen anything that leads
me to believe that way you will defeat
him as the clock gets down you know to
one minute for the very start of the
game yep agreed
yep he needs to move he's looking at
Bishop b5 I think Bishop b5 that move
looks interesting I thought maybe he was
trying to induce u6 maybe there would
have been tactics on the undefended
Bishop but settles on Queen c7 a nice
way to overprotect the knight and say
that if you castlelong which he does
maybe there's tactics now don't I don't
see any thing quickly right just make
Ryan Bishop do you may threaten vicious
h5 it's somebody should be 5ne just make
a move here right just go so king b1
here makes sense we always like our King
to be on b1 it feels like what else it
should be too as mentioned a 45 maybe
that's why calculating Knight g4 to see
what's happening if I try to go for the
H bond but yeah just you gotta move you
down in a minute on the clock this is
yeah unfortunately is moving a little
bit too slow and you want be fine
so moves you know that we're we're
mentioning and all those things but
again it's really just you get worried
you're about to see another one with the
writing on the wall but okay well we'll
stop being a broken record let's look at
the instructive aspects of Bishop b5
because you kind of been inducing a bad
trade for I mean what does Mike do here
actually by the way I mean you're
threatening d7 c6 is not gonna work as
of Knight takes c6 so you induce this
night away from the critical spot in the
center and now you start the attack with
a four I actually really like there
should be five and I like what's going I
just hate that it took them 45 seconds
to do it
Dani there's definitely a tactic here
well actually there are 85 or some is
you an ic695 Bishop before you take b6
and then take a 7
that looks pretty awesome there's an IC
16 and Bishop h6 Queen b7 mate
okay please if I know I think you see a
take b6 o dirty girl knight c6 you
called it well I thought it was doing it
even before Bishop b4 this is way better
there was a bit better this is crushing
wayy bouncing back with uh with you know
what a way he's doing right now he's
away ye it's fun
he's going with an immortal attack very
nice actually Wesley shaking his head
way he pulls away ye and bounces back
with a much-needed victory yeah actually
about line with taking on a seven I
don't think ting gonna be six or she
didn't work because there's Bishop takes
c3 pawn takes e7 Bishop takes b2 but I
had King to do you get Queen a3 okay
yeah exactly
but I look great now here fisherman a6
check so he took takes rook up to d6
Bishop a6 he's gonna have to deal with
King d8 but then Queen b7 and black is
sort of stuck oh took their I guess he's
going up the exchange yeah Queen 66
Bishop d6 pawn takes b6 but what I'm
seeing also is 30 seconds left less than
it should be straight forward but okay
Bishop back to d3 now played Bishop d3
you want to just simplify the positioned
okay Brooke g1 is fine too but at some
point just Bishop d3 get another set of
pieces off the board yep he finds it and
let's hear it for some way yi right
let's hear it for the boys that was a
great decision to Bishop d3 just trading
off those bishops no trouble what's a
bit I spent a summer in Russia I know I
know
no you you you had the right call there
especially when you don't have that much
time getting rid of that piece to
liquidate into a what should be a
winning endgame but yep you know when I
see was like rook h1 being played
doesn't give me great confidence that
white is going even though he should so
let's see c5 from that move there he's
threatening rook up three here yep rook
up three keys are you keen e7 he's gonna
work at four and then Brooke g3 to f3
and I can't do anything that was
interesting no he has to play b3 I guess
but then Brooke $88 counter don't like
we're just happy that he's down on time
he's not the flag again these are leaf
losing a game like this would be what
they call a backbreaker
yep I like you for though honestly I
really like that move but can't you over
be it you just take that pawn be to
check yeah but I think I think you
haven't wanted to give up the pawn to
create the open space that the rooks
need to win
open files rooks over yet give up the
pawn with check nice move by Wesley
keeping his opponent confused under time
pressure King see one mega rookie one
check various form submission before
should be played should before is like
only move territory no before actually
also is good I everything okay you take
away the f4 square so who after rookie
rookie one check it should be five
rookie three okay rookie - awesome keys
do allowed rookie three treat rooks he
one rookie one checked rookie what check
wins the bishop right well no that's
Roque one check but no oh yeah okay
barely King c2 and you trade before I
get it for okay you're right so you got
a trade now takes no is winning on time
though instantly moving because there's
no time on the clock you just get a
feeling is it just we're gonna be right
where we've been look at that move King
up for oh my god what a crushing move oh
it hurts it hurts it hurts it does way
east smiles a little bit it's like ah
the time the time pressure is real I
mean Wesley just was euphoric over there
he just he celebrated even this is gonna
be the last game of this three minutes
hot rolled Yasser ser one goes
backbreaker indeed yep
yeah I just love that yes it's here with
us yes were you at are you and you're
you're at home right I saw the beautiful
bookshelf behind you I hope I hope it's
okay with with the wifey that you're up
this late yeah no I'm happy y'all stirs
here always loved speaking to us or even
if it's him speaking at us while we're
doing this commentary but 96 okay we the
King's Indian I just tuned in over here
so once again we're you playing for
something entertaining exciting and
we'll see if he's the other like that
it's to cure this one
well I was he is the one who should be
very comfortable in King's Indian
structures because he has a lot of
experience yes he lost that game to
Hikaru and the white side of the 2015
cyghfer Cup yeah that was but then he
also won the next time they played he
Kings Indian yeah and so he's had great
experience since the best dealers in the
world and the King's Indian it doesn't
have to be tactical look at the position
right now it's clearly it's closed up
it's a positional battle night before
here I think got a game against Sam
Shanklin and the black side of this
position and the game ends in a draw
this was probably 2011 US Championship
Bishop takes f3 here you know because
you can't say put the Queen because
makes it to comes it take this night a6
and from blacks point of view say I'm
gonna go in I teach five play f5 you
have these double F pawns from White's
perspective you're like look at my
monstrous Queen side initiative you're
not an a6 terrible it's typical kind of
Kings Indian play here in our my gaming
it's Sam was very interesting and in the
draws mentioned but Wesley focused
Wesley with knowledge of these positions
should be feeling quite at home here so
let's see black playing 95 yeah I don't
know what he's thinking so long about 95
and a 5 is just the the thematic way to
play the position you kind of have to
try to okay 97 is saying I'm gonna play
the same ideas f5 but I'm trying to be a
little more prepared to protect the
Queen side but typically these positions
you can't really stop White's attack
right you can maybe hope to contain it
for a little bit but the point is I I'm
usually in favor of 9 h5 because it
opens up the knight have four
possibilities and other kind of dynamic
ways that is it you know it's just fair
to say that if you really start focusing
on just offending White's breakthrough
of c5 and not using your own aggressive
play on the Kings side that you know the
writing is on the wall and and white
eventually will win on the Queen side
yep so so okay but grace you're gonna
come to h4 I guess
yeah actually now you can consider
playing f4 Queen h4 g5 h 5 etc because
we're playing f4 now the bishop on
everyone doesn't get h3e sick yeah I
think that's key that's one of the main
reasons as Robert drew said YF for us to
be careful for black too early because
of this light score a problem but I like
Queen h4 first but again I don't care if
it's f4 community for first I just want
him to play it in two seconds not 17
seconds right okay here comes f4 you
have to play for a4 and and and try to
it's matin bake time yeah f4 you can
even play g5 work f6 rookie h6 the
bishop on f1 is a very good defensive
piece for the time being because it will
also help so what's the tactic coming
well blacks not even gonna take f2 you
only want to open up defense I don't
think you're taking up to here I think
you're just playing g5 I like that move
because you can't take on a 6 they just
losing a very important defensive Pia
this guy's needed for later purposes so
do you go through with typical again
King's Indian counterpart not a for nu
and b5 I don't love b5 here as much as I
doing some other ones with d6 I guess
the possibility here it is yeah opening
up the diagonal and the d5 square well
what did he just take it the bishop on
d2 is stuck which is a big problem yeah
no it's one of those funny positions
where you know white is doing all these
things that we normally see is
strategically really potentially
dangerous for black but because of the
double pawns it's not like a traditional
say Robert like a same ish Kings Indian
where White's pawn structure is totally
intact for white right here white has
other problems so black can just take
these pawns and maybe play a different
type of game maybe he doesn't have to
get checkmate to win this one yeah
backing up I think he's saying you know
what you gave me a lot of pawns you've
got double pawns this isn't an easy safe
structure for white like it normally can
be in II Kings Indian so yep
bishop c3 so you can play moves like
Knight to b6 if you need to try to trade
those nice but King H is obviously a
smart move
getting your King off that diagonal you
can decide if you don't buy Knight b6
and f6
yeah I you can put a six I was gonna say
even a six is a move that I like yeah
so now if a six I can't take because the
rooks hanging but you can play you could
play Knight b6 and know maybe make sick
I got a showdown the analysis board cuz
it was a blunder by me that would have
been a really sweet tactic everybody
Knight b6 allows take you can't take
with the pawn and if you take with the
Queen say goodbye the lady as soon as
soon as I said it you started responding
I was like oh that wouldn't have worked
that's yes I was waiting for that trap
you know you were waiting for the whole
time
dirty Whoopi one no take d5 definitely
take d5 Hank me a trade
mr. Sandman make me a trade so take on
d5 you take with a rook I've Knight b6
if you take with the pond
yeah if work takes Knight b6 and if you
take with the pawn it just it just feels
bad I mean you're opening up oh man I
just don't even know I feel good from oh
he's gonna sack the exchange Wesley's
gonna do it wait Queen b3 take on d5
eighteens b7 Ken's gonna Knight takes c3
there yeah they're gonna be 535 and then
take on C yeah you know what he's doing
Wesley's creating problems for his
opponent to solve with limited time on
the clock and that's how same idea
though okay six now Bishop a 695 and
that way you trade off more pieces of
965 now and take this on three agree now
watch out for that a pawn that's what
actually kind of scares me yeah I think
that's the only way 596 Queen c7 he's
gonna play rook b8 it's a bishop define
right yep yeah I'll get rook b8 though
trade and play for and then white should
be better here
White's down upon but is better because
the black spawns can't move or his white
she's gonna plant his upon 886 yeah
better but probably shouldn't be enough
if he's gonna win in ways time trouble
is efficiency for Queen D 325 and then
way he's gonna lose on time this is
exactly how I predict this game that
Queen d3 here you almost want to stop c4
yeah I was gonna say you want to stop
this lake that's true this c4 idea so he
does it I like that move by Wesley very
patient gonna bring the Queen to d5 kind
of inch his way in here maybe Queen yes
Queen d7 okay Queen d7 I think was you
can sell my pawn from pushing now were
you looking for desperate counter play
yeah the Kings just gonna hide here give
up the h-bomb play a7 now even Queen a
favorite even better
the bishop can hide Bishop can't hide
nowhere to run to baby nowhere to hide
and Wesley so is looking like a
confident a confident two-seat right now
proving why he is the second highest
rated one of the second highest rated
Blitzen bullet players on chess calm
behind everyone knows Nakamura so Robert
Wesley so strong get those Chesbrough a
chest bra emotes out we're gonna take a
quick break everybody before we start
the one-minute portion super super inch
interesting and instructive stuff don't
go anywhere
bullet coming right up
[Music]
will we see a a 10-game deficit overcome
in the bullet portion it would be the
first time ever Robert but I'm open to
new things you are you a try chess you
all these days you open to trying new
chess things I'm definitely open but I
don't think that a 10-game deficits
gonna be overcome in this matchup was
they so has been more impressive when
the players are down in their time
travel so I don't see how I don't know
there's enough time to get ten wins in
four what are you so I this is always
they sewing this one very impressive
performance by him well indeed indeed it
was and remind everybody that of course
they're playing to not just win this
match but to move on we talk about the
prizes we talk about the prizes to start
thank you to everyone who has donated so
far up 256 maybe we increased that a
little bit for the players efforts for
those who are into into throwing some
chess support this way we we check in
now with with what the players are doing
as we get set to start here Wesley sat
back down he's been taking a sip of what
looked like a protein drink there
hopefully it doesn't have any caffeine
in it cuz he doesn't look like he needs
any more energy his plays have certainly
been energetic and yep you know I we
just got a stat in there that was easy
three and OH in the 3-1 segment of the
speech Chess Championships he's not here
he he beat Carlsen and now wait ye I
didn't even know he beat Carlson and
remember that that's my boy I didn't
know that yeah I do remember the the
match with Carlsen really got out of
hand and bullet where Magnus really was
just kind of on another level but that
that's a surprising stat thank you stat
boy appreciate that Doron all so let's
see bullet we see a Spanish we're not
getting a Berlin thankfully we're gonna
go home thank you early castles yep
Bishop d7 think of ever being here
before as well okay this lines and t6
and this tends to be a poem before that
can be too advanced some lines we saw
this opening earlier and when way he
blended rook takes G to check wait long
ago at this point I know he was doing
very well and then blundered like you
said yeah but this is a similar line
that it's exactly this should be fun
yeah bishop wait way you shouldn't
hesitate at all to get that same
position again just let's let's uh numb
oh and now this is the type of position
that can really be hard to hold for the
next several moves on the light squares
so that d5 pawn is that actually gonna
last in that square so you can't take
now because a5 is a super strong move
though everyone it separates these two
pawns forevermore so b4 will always be a
target right so what if I'd so now I'm
throwing and take on d5
how you doing most protected by moving
your night so nicely six but he put that
after such a long think and now wait
Queen d7 I guess c3 c3 this is this is
very very good for white yep the clock
situation still doing wonders from black
we're gonna say that a lot was was a so
being on the black side this position
but c3 now I think was he overlooked if
he shook his head
understanding that thing you're not
gonna yeah that there's just there's
just no clear way to to get the pawn
back
so nine of five okay isn't that a six
tonight back on c6
I don't know if it was necessary that
looks nine before is actually very
strong protecting a d5 on yeah now he
has to deal with those threats that's a
strong way to do it chief or maybe oh oh
do it g4 g4 so in 95 hey chief or this
time Robert do you do like it I'll tell
you one thing about g4 Robert it's
always good or bad one of those sure I
agree with that sentiment I don't really
know what other side's doing I thought
that White's just take on each war yeah
and not only that he's taking a lot of
time to make moves that but Wesley using
a little bit of time shuffle to but
White's King is not safe so work comes
next
this is 97 what's he doing was king away
he's gonna be blunder is no Queen
Oh 96 Wesley Wesley reacts with the face
to the hand famine palm to the face
let's get let's get the let's get the
palm to the face emotes going here that
was funny you know I think Danny he's
just Mike 888 he was completely winning
but of course King f8 tempting because
there's 97 so that is way he fighting
back in this but that's why I we were
right to say 97th of horrible movie that
way you but I mean Wesley blunders right
back
yep and he didn't challenge way he's
connection because I would have thought
about it with how much lag there's been
and he's flagged way many times yeah
okay so what's going on here you could
have taken on c4 and said he's just
bring as many for a play f5 to follow
that way he gains more space this is
like a stone wall type structure and
some but it looks like it's like a good
stone wall for white I mean you just
feel like whatever white is already just
accelerated the attack to this level
it's only a matter of time before we
undermine in the light squares you can
retreat the knight from f3 and even kick
kick it out of e4 but I don't I'm biased
for these types of structures with white
because I just don't believe in any
attack against the fiend kind of
structure that doesn't have a you go and
a slab in it
well yeah I agree with you the white is
very solid here and this is just looking
good for white but how do you break
through that's a big problem well the
point is like you have this undermining
tension and black can't ever take
anything without having positional
problems the bishop on c8 is bad yeah so
you build up rugby one I still think at
some point you're gonna retreat this
night to try to get a three although now
now the black has established g4 you're
not you're not really gonna be playing
for f3 anymore yep and in fact black can
play c5 at some point to open up the
position especially after f3 if you Mele
after I'm definitely gonna play c5 now
I'm definitely not complacency 5 is your
Knights I'm Peter but okay so yeah oh
yeah this is nice technique though so be
it or take them b5 I'm not sure I'm not
happy with either and neither its way
yeast taking time cuz it's frustrating
yep so c5 here take I was gonna say take
with the A+ you could get c5 but you
were right c5 right away it's even
better well b7 is really not a very
important pawn you can even just take
back on b5 now but I thought 92 p7
sacrificed to a pawn temporarily wait
was this c6 square you want to put the
knight on b7 anyway so Bishop takes me
six four it's not playing nice c6 and
Queen g7 black and kind of get some
counter play over there you want to put
the knight on e4 if you're black and
even maybe h h5 and h4 yeah this
actually suddenly Wesley the the space
on the Queen side didn't amount to
anything concrete and now we're starting
to feel like 94 h 5 h 4 black is black
is working it Oh that'd be five pawn so
take on c6 and take her the Queen on c6
no black is better yeah black is better
all the sudden so plague I don't even
know it's a queen somewhere Oh 885 is
very nice no fear he's got to work it 96
now breathing six bring it to c4 trust
your intuition use the Force no you take
with the deep on the mesh structures you
could pretty Queen on d5 it doesn't
really matter I don't think but I would
I thought taking the deep only now he
has to back the bishop oh he takes it
yeah play he's gonna work a5 and win
that pawn to c5
oh but if he does ables de pon yeah
which I'm not just not I don't think he
should lose but I think he gave away his
winning chances with that rooks Assoc
good move if you trade on b8 you have
this outside pass pawn so I know I'm
check I was trying to be five Queen a
former p1 check is your king and yeah
now you got to be worried that your king
becomes the one that's open okay because
of that he takes the ladies off the
board I think rightfully so and it
should should be a peaceful result so h5
so you need to somehow get this d4 move
in I know I ain't gonna do it but you
might just be nervous though if you're
what you wanted his Jeep on oh wow
not gonna be an easy win I mean easy
drill anymore
for yeah he's still even on material he
was up a pawn before now it's even so
that black is better
can you play d4 and then takes in d3
maybe he's just missing his chance here
yeah are you Brooke on d7 d 4 d 4 now
d4 it's not G 4 but it's deep here in c4
c6 oh there's the deep on King g5 ok
easy smartly actually kind of just plain
tickle here everybody gaining a little
bit of time on the clock matters now
black has to be winning yeah you'd think
there must be a win here with the pawn
that for advanced Brooke c6 or something
like that oh that's a nice idea yeah
bring the rook back and make a trade huh
there it is there goes the Rose for it
so what he did is he any wife
Oh what is he doing I don't think work
t5 one because there's tf1 back okay but
no he's gonna give check and check he's
trying to check to get free booze but 77
he kicks the rook away never up c1 check
d2 he won
it's over yeah that's why work c5 was so
strongly to Fleur square from the brook
d2 next Wesley is smartly playing these
things out though given the time
situation and I gotta be honest I'm
shocked we've seen a time scramble that
went way ease way where both sides were
living on the increment so at least we
know that likely be the lag wouldn't
won't be a reason an under mutual time
pressure but
he worked at that game if he wins
another one he's gonna be twerking it
yep that was well played Danny you know
it's funny I thought rook c5 in that
position to play Brooke d5 but I realize
you're taking away the d5 squares yeah
super instructive great point yeah
really nice played playing no with no
time on the clock my way either really
awesome so let's see we have a what's
eat still eight games so he's won two
games to cut through me from ten to
eight he technically has time you know
there is enough time left if he wins all
his bullet games and we do get surprised
when the player who was struggling with
his time trouble ends up being so far
the superior bullet player but you know
of course as I said with a huge
advantage we heard a Cara Nakamura say
this last week sometimes in Europe so
many games it's hard to really keep your
focus and to just have that sort of
winning yeah when he ins the killer
instinct but then again two in a row I
mean you got to be getting some
confidence if you're away ye right who
knows why not win three in a row right
that's called a winning streak that's
the Cleveland Indians once learned and
so right now he's position I would have
taken on g5 played f4 and gone for the
d5 um but it's actually what he's doing
right now he's saying if you go c4 I'm
gonna when I use a queen d4 probably but
I could take on g5 place yeah for before
play Bishop d1 to f3 take over the a fun
this is just everything is going like
swing so I'm not sure if you play Queen
d4 for the first time he's actually up
on time so Wesley Wesley has a match
ahead of him here yeah great use of the
clock honestly by way right there so I
take on G take on g5 v g5 sync the Queen
in with f4 and do Roberts plan just go
ahead f4 Bishop d1 Bishop f3 and I don't
think that okay seven is strong too I
don't it frenzies it threatens east six
in some positions I think so Brooke a
one yeah play R okay one just just
anchor it in and I think e six is
actually a ton of tactics looming here
for black you're pretty 8 right here
actually II 6 is very scary
position c6 Bishop up there's
ah miss your rep sticks back okay no he
has to play Bishop six back but even
then I think Queen just c5 no no Queen
III I guess Queen III threatening e7 and
Queen h6 at the same time partner
look at that Queen h6 but what do you do
now you're losing the e pawn queen h6 v
no we should fix that v is interesting
yeah but don't get back ranked Bishop
takes f5 doesn't work now so please
yeah but Wesley's defended well at some
point d4 is gonna be very problematic
way yep
agreed so d4 now I'll get here here
comes d4 so King f1 please c7 just to
avoid d4 but that's now this is a real
problem because now c3 spell yeah way he
has totally let the thread slip away in
this one you should have played the f4
plane that you were talking about
honestly just to d4 okay any point d4 is
can gonna be good now Queen 63 is a lot
of ones yep
and Wesley stops the bleeding as you
said you called it said maybe he had
lost his focus a little bit and knows
that he does need to win a couple games
here can't allow a complete 10 game
comeback well I honestly thought that
was a great position for way you know I
think it was he just played rook a7
which gave black that necessary counter
play to trade rooks and take over the
equal you should just want to f4 bishop
d1 Bishop f3 and actually in bullet
chest it's much easier to play with that
kind of sustained pressure then allowing
your opponents or the easy like
reflexive moves yeah yeah good point so
let's see here we this is a very topical
line played at the highest level many
times we saw was they draw chromic in
this opening you see increment play at
many different times I feel like we've
made more we make more references to top
OTB games you know elite classical chess
when Wesley Seok plays these matches I
feel like than anyone else yeah he's
very principled player and working out
for him very well
and in this particular game well whites
I think wait actually was this how the
game druid mighty shaking his head maybe
maybe it feels like doesn't want to draw
but maybe doesn't have a choice this is
how chrome Nick and so drew their game I
believe nineties five yep yep and they
just take a draw so I mean okay not the
worst result for wayy given he's black
but at this point every every second off
the clock that way he doesn't get a win
just seals the deal so yeah he's down
nine points and there's only 16 and for
sixty minutes 40 seconds of counting
down yo not almost no chance at this
point but he has made it more
interesting by being competitive in this
segment on the 3-1 segment it was 8 to 1
and was he's favored yeah that's that's
just a slaughter and really impressive
play by was he there in this bullet
section we have seen we pick up steam in
effect look at their bullet ratings you
used nine twenty nine twenty two and was
it twenty nine seventy one so was he
just ran to the scene do you see that
did something maybe he maybe he was
getting some water for the cat yeah I
don't know I saw him running to the sink
and run back and well we're back to a
similar kind of structure we just had
right almost almost exactly the same
game but perhaps this time wayyy
there's a little bit smarter about
sinking making sure that pawn on e5
doesn't go anywhere oh but when I Wesley
Wesley knows he wasn't happy with that
one it wants to change the dynamics but
the light squares watch out light square
is there that mission one sees who now
has new a new lease on life on the aged
seven square well if Brooke up sevens a
nice defensive move making sure you keep
everything guarded your Bishop on e7 is
is the late checking it to here
yeah Queen e2 I think to me six will be
to reply and that's what's the nice
start working up seven is Uli yeah great
point I like always like it when you
play before because you play see before
see before my bishop comes to b3 and
you're gonna have a problem the d5
square so West City Cakes but now here
comes rookie one rookie one feels like a
super dangerous to say
I mean just to start opening this thing
up like that so how does but like we
said top players are not afraid of
dangerous decisions
no sir can take on c5 I think you should
take on c5 be c5 Bishop c5 I take on of
seven and been shale Queen d3 years I
think that's that's what we're gonna see
Queen you'll take because if Knight
takes Queen d3 is an actual Fork of the
two pawns so I think Queen takes f7
should be played oh he takes her tonight
but here comes the fork same mission six
no he's got ideas okay so you got him
here Brooke working okay Bishop b2 I
thought rookie two isn't we played wait
can you go Bishop f2 to g3 oh snap but
you just go a just h3 and it's not that
okay rookies six even here I thought
maybe you should play rookie sick you
could take on h7 by the way would check
there and then I've taken on g3 oh
that's actually really clever but he
didn't see it and I thought maybe he
should have had the rook on d6 cuz of
pressure here but okay well but he
didn't he still should have something
you think c4 open up and he goes for it
I think white is doing very well right
c5 now keep pushing that pawn yep no
reason to stop push him baby
yep sees no c6 might be going too far
okay 95 is tricky Russkies but there's
no frets so maybe you can play c6 anyway
oh no ya takin then the Queen would take
back the Queen e4 you have to go oh why
do you the biggest issue here yeah
you've got this like lingering potential
mating net as Wesley is pointing out and
suddenly there's all kinds of problems
whoa Bishop you know one only move what
is he doing can you just go Brooke take
c1 check or this both I think rook takes
he would check was better yeah I mean
you didn't just win the Queen yeah but
he okay but he's gonna win this anyway
given that there's no time and and wow
what a game that backfired we've had a
few of those today for the most part I
think Wesley has you know one that won
games with a similar pattern of being up
on time in critical moments and just you
know out calculating and being
more creative in this opponent but I
think there's been three or four games
the way you really let get away and I
feel like this was one of them
yep it's definitely a number of games
where we liked ways position and all of
a sudden we look seven moves later and
it's like whoa what just happened here
it's a totally different game altogether
so yep forty for him he is he's
struggling Wesley so is like a little
kid when he wins I love it he just
smiles there's no shake just love it
he's so happy yeah he's so happy and
he's you know he's a guy who absolutely
loves chess so yeah he loves chess no
matter what but especially when he's
winning and you always see that in his
press conferences you know he yes these
interviews and he's always just I was
really happy to play I want to thank my
competitors for being so tough and well
wayy despite the score I mean yo when we
talked to was the after he'll say that
and this is a really tough match for him
I see he's laughing again I don't know
maybe he's laughing it and the thought
of whatever I just had to say you might
not listening so I think that Wesley
actually does bear a striking
resemblance to Diego Dora the Explorer's
cousin I don't even know Diego looks
like go ahead and Google Diego Dora the
Explorer Diego Dora the Explorer's
cousin Diego that's actually kind of
adorable yeah so yeah it's pretty funny
but in this this game isn't white just
much better here take on d5 place c4
have the two bishops yeah good stuff for
white straightforward and we're getting
in the territory where even though we
started feeling maybe it may be an
interesting comeback coming with two
games in a row for way you to start
bullet Wesley has recovered
yeah c4 here let's mention you gotta
take on d5 open the C file for your rook
which is perfectly placed there
nice yep play even kingi - no need to
cancel he could castle but King you
choose but even even good and that's a
note - perhaps or less experienced
players were told
keep your King safe you know castle it
you know King in the center and the
endgame is actually quite strong so yeah
now we should take c5 take with the
bishop and you have a better structure -
you can play a free-kick the night out
that's what he's gonna do I don't know
if I'd played for because yeah I don't
think you should go as far as you four
but even like bishop be one king of to
kind of sit on this position a little
bit and prepare you for
I like Bishop be one king of to strive
for you for look he's gonna go Fisher on
him he's gonna play h5 and try to take
h7
is that going to Fischer I thought
Fischer's taking h7 e on your Bishop
trap so what I mean you go Fischer or
you go home you know but okay i likey
for though G 4G 4G 4G for no I want you
for now you've been all about G for
today even when it's been very bad all
about the base all about g4 uh you know
this is uh the 9h8 is not exactly the
best piece I've seen today oh it's back
in the action no the space spatial
avenge is very nice yeah over for white
you can now just put a 5s is creating
another weakness and the other side of
the board you might work a one here to
try that open the eight I like this move
Bishop a4 now d5 no takes first and
maybe then d5 yeah but b5 okay well you
can take those c6 with tempo and then
just work on the d6 night maybe that's
interesting thought this your bed should
be 3 or 94 here just try oh now I'm not
definitely at night c4 because that I
thought you'd think what the Brooklyn
someone okay I think blacks kind of
getting honest wasn't night 64 check
just hanging a second oh my gosh it was
it it was again so teeny-weeny one saves
but I was looking at earlier but there's
a bishop on b3 so obviously yeah we're
now all of a sudden black is the one
with the past on yep probably not enough
to win
with okay with no time on the clock for
either player we're probably gonna see a
scramble finish regardless yep would not
be surprised if way you lost in time
yeah I wouldn't either although not
anymore
now I would be surprised yeah it's gonna
be a draw yep I don't see a winning plan
yeah king c6 put the bishop back on f7
okay now you're just inducing and ducing
weaknesses should be pretty easy to draw
six h3 gh3 bishop f3k everybody gets
traded
everybody gets traded f3 for c4 and draw
look at that simple chess that's so
funny you can sort of check force the
draw Wesley smiles he's got a great
smile can someone put a Diego hat on
this kid I love it Diego wears like like
an Indiana Jones like rope around him
too then you know how I feel about
Indiana Jones your big Indian Jones guy
thank you thank you for saying that with
the least amount of enthusiasm possible
you know what Danny I've been talking
for the last three-plus hours and I
don't want talk about Indiana Jones
right now okay I'm glad we aired that
really glad we got that out yeah we're
talking with Temple of Doom Indiana
Jones okay yeah I mean obviously the
Last Crusade is by far the best go Sean
Connery or get out okay just checking
yeah if you if I what if if you even
mentioned the one with Shia LaBeouf no
no that come on that was atrocious and
I'm a Shia LaBeouf you know aficionado
all right you love to see a music video
with child above yo one day I want to
have Shia LaBeouf on a chef show like
that's like a light that's like a bucket
list item for me
I mean maybe one day and also maybe one
day this Bishop 180 will see new life
and there is
maybe one day maybe not one day no new
life yet don't count your chickens wait
95 use my queen five check yeah that's a
problem Queens coming day five upon its
a pawn and this Bishop remains trapped
on a - it's a bishop see 300 castles
long loves it I was not expecting that
but now
it's your probably weren't expecting cuz
it's no good but actually g1 actually
yeah suddenly there's at least something
something messy 56 this ship takes c4 is
also possible rook takes d6 Bishop c4 is
kind of Bishop c4 takes c3 I take e6 in
term is oo he goes for you that's feisty
feisty feisty we evolve in a world queen
that's a great move Bishop d5 is it
really that great I mean it just it's
fascinating and never up b8 maybe just
continue ignoring everything yeah don't
get made it you might get made yeah he
goes for it but yeah rook b8 rook tab
d3o f4 so trade queens then Bishop beats
you check then can I finally Castle rook
d3 should be played into a of yeah okay
maybe you bring the bishop back to b3
and
time situation yep time on the ticket II
but if you put the bishop on b3
everybody's defended now you can play
king e to double the rooks shouldn't be
a game you can lose but with only five
minutes left at this point we're
enjoying the chest and getting prepared
for interviews so yeah this is now all
of a sudden I mean black works for him
to be better here with that Bishop on c5
live rook before g5 also oh well King
chief I was really good it was king g4
not not good there I mean he was gonna
take an h2 already upon us oh I forgot a
she was hanging my bed oh my gosh wha he
just blundered the rook that's a skewer
a skewer hurts this is getting and
they're gonna smile he's just so happy
he is he's enjoying it he's putting on a
show for us right now showing why he was
he was favored to win this match
although you and I predicted a close
match similar to the stats that favored
Aronian coming in but we predicted a
very close match with Fabiano and and in
the end kind of similar here at Wesley
show is Wesley so is not playing slow
definitely not but it's not yeah it's
just like the 5 minute portion starting
with a two-game lead for wayy and was he
so comes roaring back yep and it's very
impressive what's going on here why are
you thinking at this point
Queen takes us okay at first he goes for
this line yep so from blacks point of
view you know that White's can play c4
at some point you can play c5 yourself
if they don't play c4 so now it you can
put c5 there it is
and by taking on c5 you give yourself to
d4 square so it looks like you gave
yourself a bad c3 pawn the reality
you've solidified that Square D for for
your control you can play rook a c1 you
can play see for yourself coming up
look at this Queen B for what is he just
trying to transition into a better
endgame so play give it a 4 here may
work c1
their work see one first I would have
you trade Queens on before I'm first the
C file now you can play Knight d4 to hit
the fish money six and if you take on
before my native Maya Knight will
eventually finds where the c6 Corso a
for again as possible Bishop h6 is
tempting it just looks like white is
slightly better here and has a bit of
nagging pressure so hey bagging yep
nagging sorry I was just I didn't mean
that you didn't mean it did meet it okay
I forgive you then okay just wanna do it
just wanted to say that while I was on
camera sounds good so a five okay so now
you're trying to create a new weakness
like took on a five so if the Queen a
five now Queen a five rook a five that's
gonna be the case there's a problem to a
seven in d5 squares and now I'd play c4
because the ninety-four it's really nice
losing its protection so he's doing this
so he's essentially saying do you to go
for c3 lose a seven and even if you're
able to make that full-on trade the a
some puns more valuable so here a five
there it goes
a black and we're crossing that line
where there's a a chance this is the
final game in the match rubber how much
times loves about a minute on the total
clock so this probably the second Alaska
rook takes d4 is just yeah all the
sudden black ran away with da pond
things look no does that work over okay
for there it is a nice c3 Bishop e6 or
something like that yeah very nice
defends a to unleashes the discovery on
d8 Wesley shakes his head
so we're gonna be three first one of
them even bring the rook this way to c2
also but so we have one last game
one less game we fit in one more way e
gets a game that's that's worth a few
bucks and remember that the total prize
fund is split based on win percentage
after the winner takes home the the made
me Jorah t of the prize and the the
biggest prize of all moving on to the
next round then every game after that is
worth probably somewhere between 50 to
100 bucks maybe that's kind of cool
ya know it's nice to have the
opportunity to play for a little bit
more cash and I mean for both these
players they just want to win every game
so that's pretty good to see time is up
finally this is the last game of the
match don't go anywhere we're gonna talk
to both these players in just a moment
as soon as the match is done yep and
here way he's playing like me in bullet
games on chess comm server because you
went horrible openings and on tilt well
you know I don't think it's that bad you
know you've hit 95 here in the Queen
comes the age but I do a double Bishop
sacrifice to end this match shall we man
it would be pretty sweet make Alaska
proud so 95 7 well I was gonna say 95 94
that's how you work it but he's prepared
I have a feeling we're gonna see
something super sassy to end this match
everybody buckle up yep you could drop a
knight on each six that's a bughouse
checkmate playing 95 he's patiently
waiting for this idea he'll probably
play 92 now no but they need to deal
with night before so he doesn't want
that night before comes anyway so he's
gonna allow the capture on d3 Oh finally
played 95 I don't know I didn't do it
earlier but by playing 95 well blacks 84
at some point now yeah I agree with you
that 95 was was what the doctor ordered
a fiver ok 95 why should just castlelong
they're actually a mini em you can just
cast almost a rook h3 and yeah there's
still all kinds of h-file problems
whoa a night event g7 is not a great
piece now unless you're playing f6 for
example to you know try to kick this
night away and do the Rockaway yep we do
we go through this already today yep
uh-huh
how about to attack though terror squad
Rebecca oka Deline Iraq or oka Castle I
like this move rook h3 as well though
and one of the rare times you see Wesley
whoa clearly much lower on time if you
take that set just go 906 we're just
we're just Oh Knight f6 is even better
because you would have kept it close but
even now rook takes h5 can 95 first rook
takes h5 without thinking yeah okay but
why wasn't taking on on e3 good there
for Wesley it probably was and then deep
Queen d2 and Queen f2 was mate you know
it's really good I so not a lot of time
here you have to take h5 anyway let him
take on b2 cuz it's made on g7 so is
that five coming for white like what's
good now he's got to take III in defense
so okay now I need my oh no no he wasn't
come to g5 I guess he wants Knight of
three and I chief oh that's not bad
actually it's actually looks scary for
blonde yeah you can you could have taken
on b5 there too with the Queen and then
at 95 but he's just playing safe moves
so Queenie 525 threatens a 95 and then
Queen h8 is made missive 95 in Queen AJ
with Queens ever was mean one crew g7
was made one but it doesn't matter it's
maybe two with one second on the clock
that's how you end the speeches
championship and style Wesley so that
was awesome Wesley takes the cake but
but the but the match finishes and in
exciting fashion either way the Hawaii
twins that last game so he cuts he
actually wins the bullet portion of the
match indeed well we're gonna ask both
players to rejoin us now we have unmuted
their microphones Wesley can you hear us
[Music]
yes I can hear you loud and clear can
you hear me great yeah
wait wait can you hear us well thank you
both for the for the match it was super
exciting chess a lot of great moments
and obviously congratulations Wesley for
for a wonderful performance I know those
last couple games probably didn't go the
way you wanted but evident but in wayy
how does it feel to win it win a couple
of the nicer games in the match there
two to make sure you had some fun here
even though I know the day didn't go the
way you wanted are you feeling are you
feeling ready for your game that starts
in about two and a half hours yes well
um let's start with you it felt that a
lot of these games were very close very
close on the board you were both playing
a pretty high level of chess but
consistently under time pressure and and
Wesley creating a lot of problems for
you when you were down on the clock
being creative being resourceful how did
you feel about how you managed your time
in the match and and maybe would have
would have done things differently
another time around is it is it
something you you were aware of that you
were consistently getting under time
pressure were you trying to make efforts
to speed up or is it just something that
in hindsight became really clear sorry
sorry a confusing question I'll try to
ask though but but lastly let me ask you
you having seen you play a few of these
matches you are probably the most
principled grandmaster that Robin and I
have ever seen you're you're always
playing the mainlines always challenging
your opponent is that just is that just
your your approach to the game even in
blitz not not messing around you see
some players play crazy first move
openings but you're you're consistently
going into mainline stuff is that is
that an approach that that you really
feel is your is your thing yeah I'd like
that
approach because with so little time
it's best to get a position that players
really used to and I've tried the
experimental approach many times in the
past and they have been really gone well
like in the like in Lyon for example but
when I got the lead in the match I
decided to just stay principle because
you know if the way is the one who needs
to do the catching up but right it the
is that something that helps you also
learn from your blitz games I was
wondering that as somebody who plays a
lot of openings that you wouldn't
necessarily not play in real games in
fact you even repeated some of your own
games right you had the repetition which
was the same as your game with chrome
Nick right and so is it a lot of people
I think wonder how they can learn from
their blitz games online and do you feel
that you're consistent sort of very
principled approach means that you're
even you're even constantly improving
and you know learning things about the
structures you play even and even in
blitz matches like this yeah definitely
there's always something to learn from
experience
but actually I'm pretty disappointed by
my level of play today because you know
especially in the five minutes in the
bullet section I miss pretty simple
stuff and you know once I got the lead I
decided to just wait for him to make
mistakes
it was very aggravating for me to those
the first two out of three games so I
thought I have an uphill battle to climb
and and I had to come back from from
behind but you know winning six in a row
in the five minute was clearly unreal
and I went up made it without a lot of
help from we you know actually before
the match I wasn't exactly sure how it
would go because I haven't really played
way in this rapid
and I haven't I don't really see him
playing so much online lips so I didn't
know what to expect I was pleasantly
surprised when the polls say that I have
like a 66% chance in favor of me so that
encouraged me a bit yeah I think we he's
a great player you know it's only
nineteen years old he's much younger
than me um maybe right now he's a big
focus on the long game part of chess but
right but for me I just played through
rapid tournaments in a row so I still
used to it
well ye do you do you think that's true
that maybe the fact that you're right in
the middle and then in in downs au of a
classical tournament long time controls
was it hard to play such fast time
controls online just yeah I think
difficult to play after some classical
games and enough these games
you started out winning you were up two
games in the five minute huh what were
you thinking at that point mister
well go ahead sorry it's very tough to
come back from behind then I know the
feeling I've been there before in a
blitz game you know if you keep losing
one game after the other it's really
tough mentally yeah to come back just
yeah somehow I was trying to do better
in the bullet but the last two games and
I just made some 18:1 and thing I just
well yes you seem to dominate the
three-minute portions of this speech
Chess Championships you be Giri
you'd be Carlsen and now you beat wayy
by pretty good margins is that something
you tend to play more often is that just
a time control you feel the most
comfortable in I mean how do you do it
ah well I do play a lot of two-minute
games in in chess calm because that's
what most players want to play and I
just it just happens you know do you
mean it it's like a mixture of bullet
and in five-minute games it's not that
fast
but at the same time I can think too
much I guess it just happened but
clearly in bullet I don't know what's
going on is it in you know in the in
ultimate gaming ball I didn't even
realize that I only had 16 seconds left
like I somehow forgot that if just one
minute um yes so as Levon Aronian said a
few days ago it's just I need a lot of
improvement will in bullet obviously
well if you play that well in 3 minute
and you improve and bullet people people
will people will be nervous so obviously
you played great today Wesley and and
where ye I think similar right as you
said you played some really interesting
chess and Wesley did a pretty good job
of creating problems for you under time
pressure but it's been great to have you
both Wesley you will be moving on to
face the winner if we if we bring that
up right now
vivid and lovin that's right so you'll
be here 7:00 and who would you rather
face of those of those two and and what
do you think your chances are there
let's see it stopping under Afghan right
yes yeah but under him okay all right
well either way we we wish you the best
of luck in that match of course we will
see you in that match probably a couple
months away from now of course you have
a lot of tournaments between now and
then Sinquefield Cup Olympia just a few
a few events almost almost as awesome as
the speeches championship and the
Rapidan bit well way II thank you again
very very exciting very entertaining
match and we appreciate you and we wish
you the best of luck today playing the
tournament leader in Dan's out yeah I
think it's he has a very important game
today well for me time to sleep you go
to bed wayy
good luck in your match and everybody
thank you for watching thank you to all
the fans twitch TV / chess chess calm TV
you guys have been great it's been a
really fun show today and thank you for
all the support
Wesley some moves on and we will see
everybody the next be chess championship
match we have a little bit of a break
now
not as back-to-back but actually we'll
see you Thursday August 2nd we have
Maxime vache the grove taking the on the
Cuban with three names Lainie our
Dominguez Perez Robert and I will see
you on Thursday August 2nd and until
then have a good night everybody or a
good morning depending on where you are
in night many bite
you